HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO ORDER- WE
WILL ESTABLISH A QUORUM WHEN WE
HAVE MORE MEMBERS PRESENT WE
WILL START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE TO
GET MOVING ON ON ON A BIG
AGENDA- I'D LIKE TO WELCOME THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO TODAY'S HEARING.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
THINKING THANK YOU FOR HAVING AN
INTEREST IN AND THAT EDUCATION
POLICY WE HAVE SEVENTEEN BILLS
ON FILE TODAY. AND PLEASE NOTE
THERE WILL BE HEARING THE BILL'S
IN FILE ORDER. IN FILE ORDER.
THERE ARE TWO MEASURES ON
CONSENT ARE THERE AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY SIX AND AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS
THOSE TWO ARE ON CONSENT. BEFORE
WE BEGIN OUR GENDER LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE A NEW
VICE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE HE
JUST WALKED IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEGAN DOLLY WAS A GOOD PERSON-
AND WE ALSO HAVE A ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAD IS ALSO A GOOD
PERSON. AND BUT SHE'S THE VICE
CHAIR SO WATCH OUT M. I WOULD
THAT I- I HAVE A BRIEF STATEMENT
TO READ REGARDING OUR PROCESS
TODAY. R. THE ASSEMBLY IS
STRONGLY RECOMMENDING THAT MASS
BE WARNING THE HEARING TODAY. IN
THE HEARING ROOM TODAY WE ALSO
CONTINUE TO PRACTICE SOCIAL
DISTANCING IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND AS A RESULT THERE ARE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF SEATS. ARE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ARE
WELCOME PROVIDE COMMON IN PERSON
AND THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. M. WE WILL NOT BE
TAKING OF PHONE TESTIMONY TODAY
OF ANY SORT- IFSCHOOLS SHOULD
BE OPEN THIS COMMITTEE SHOULD BE
OPEN SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING-
ONE OVER MEMBERS PLEASE REMEMBER
TO USE YOUR BAD WHEN USE THAT
DOOR BEHIND AS YOU WALK THROUGH
THAT DOOR ABOUT USING A BADGE AN
ALARM SOUNDS. AND PEOPLE COME
RUNNING OKAY SO DON'T DO THATUSE YOUR BADGE HERE SELF INTO
THAT DOOR TO THE REAR FOR
MEMBERS BUT THAT WE WILL PROCEED
WITH THEIR FIRSTITEM AB
SEVENTEEN OH THREE THAT'S WHY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS. WAS RIGHT
THERE AND YOU MISTER RAMOS YOU
MAY PROCEED. WHEN READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ARM. AND
ENCOURAGEMENT AWAY MASSES WITH
DURING TESTIMONY ALSO- IT'S YOUR
CHOICE I'M NOT WEARING ONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- AB
SEVENTEEN OH THREE WOULD
ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA INDIAN
EDUCATION ACT STUDENTS RECEIVE
INSTRUCTION ON CALIFORNIA STATE
HISTORY STARTING FROM THE THIRD
AND FOURTH GRADE THEN ON TO THE
EIGHTH GRADE WITH THEM HISTORY
ON THE ON THE UNITED STATES AND
ELEVENTH GRADE WITH GOVERNMENTAL
STRUCTURE- THROUGHOUT THE K.
THROUGH TWELVE SYSTEM.
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE HAVE
LONG EXPRESSED CONCERNS THAT THE
HISTORY TAUGHT DURING THESE
INSTRUCTIONAL PERIODS IS
INACCURATE AND MISSING OR
MISLEADING AND MANY TIMES
FOCUSING ATTENTION AWAY FROM THE
TRUE HISTORY THAT IMPACT
IMPACTED THE CALIFORNIA PEOPLE
AND ALSO THE ACTUAL
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE CALIFORNIA
PEOPLE. THE TEACHING OF OUR
TRADITIONAL LOCAL MUSIC FOR
EXAMPLE OUR HISTORY AND CULTURE.
WE WORK HARD TO BREAK THOSE
MISCONCEPTIONS MISCONCEPTIONS
THAT ALL NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE SIMILAR WHEN IN FACT THERE
ARE GREAT DIFFERENCES ONE
STEREOTYPE IS THAT ALL NATIVE
AMERICANS USE DRUMS FOR THEIR
MUSIC. WHEN IN OUR LOCAL AREAS
WE USE GOURD RATTLES IN HOPES OF
ANIMALS AND ELDERBERRY FLUTES.
THERE IS A GREAT NEED FOR
FACTUAL HISTORY. LIKE THE
TELLING OF THE CREATION OF THE
STATE MILITIAS FROM THE EIGHTEEN
SIXTIES PERIOD. THAT WAS THEIR
SOLE MISSION TO GET RID OF
INDIAN PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHERE THOSE MILITIAS
WERE PAID FOR BY TAXPAYERS
DOLLARS THAT PART OF FACTUAL
HISTORY STILL NEEDS TO BE TOLD
THROUGHOUT THE GREATER PART OF
CALIFORNIA. THERE ARE ALSO MAJOR
CONTRIBUTIONS. THAT NATIVE
AMERICANS TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. HAVE PAVE THE WAY
FOR EXAMPLE MANY ROADS TRAVEL
TODAY INTERSTATES AND HIGHWAYS
WERE ONCE INDIAN TRAILS. SO
THOSE CONTRIBUTIONS STILL NEED
TO BE ACCREDITED TO THE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE. AB SEVENTEEN
OH THREE WOULD ENCOURAGE LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES TO FORM
CALIFORNIA INDIAN EDUCATION TASK
FORCE. WITH CALIFORNIA TRIBES
LOCAL TO THE REGENTS. THIS BILL
WOULD ENCOURAGE THOSE TASK FORCE
TO DEVELOP CURRICULUM MATERIALS.
FOR USE IN TEACHING ABOUT THE
HISTORY CULTURE AND GOVERNMENT
OF LOCAL TRIBES WITH THE INPUT.
OF VOICES THAT MANY TIMES HAVE
DOLLAR OF THE PROCESS. THIS
PROCESS WOULD DEVELOP A SHARED
UNDERSTANDING OF CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST PEOPLE AND CAN BUILT ON
MUTUAL RESPECT AND
UNDERSTANDING. OF THE PRESENT
CULTURE AND HISTORY OF OUR
PEOPLE. WITH ME TODAY I HAVE
VICE CHAIRMAN JOHNNY HERNANDEZ
FROM THE SALMON WELL TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT. AND VICE CHAIR JANET
GENEVA MODEL FROM THIS OF BOBA
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN OH
THREE. AND I WILL HAVE- VICE
CHAIR. WOMAN GENEVA MAHATO GO
FIRST THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
RAMOS SO YOU HAVE TO WITNESSES
WE LIMIT THE TESTIMONY TO TWO
WITNESSES FOR TWO MINUTES EACH
AND AFTERWARDS. PEOPLE CAN AND
SHOULD COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE
AND SHARE THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL THANKS I WAS HEARING THIS
IS. HELLO MELA MY NAME SHOULD BE
A MODEL I AM THE VICE CHAIRWOMAN
FOR THE CIVIL THE BAND OF THE
SENIOR INDIANS AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF AB ONE SEVEN ZERO
THREE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEN
RAMOS FOR BRINGING THE BILL TO
LET OTHERS LEGISLATIVE FOR
CONSIDERATION IN MY OWN PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE I WAS ALWAYS ASKED IF
I LIVED IN ATP OR IF I HAD RAINY
WATER I AT MY HOME ON THE
RESERVATION. THIS WAS THE CERES
STEREOTYPE THAT MY FELLOW
CLASSMATES LEARNED IN THE
HISTORY BOOKS THAT WERE TALKED
ABOUT GRADE SCHOOL AND BECAUSE I
WAS INDIAN I MUST STILL LIVE IN
THE SAME WAY KNOWING THAT ONLY
PARTICULAR TRIBES WERE TAUGHT IN
HISTORY AND BRUTAL BATTLES
SOMEONE DID IT INDIAN STILL EVEN
EXISTED BEING IN THE FOURTH
GRADE WE WERE TAUGHT ABOUT THE
SPANISH MISSIONS WHO WERE SO
CALLED CAME TO RESCUE AND TO
CONFORM THE NATIVE PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA. THEY DID NOT TEACH
THE CHU AN ACCURATE ACCOUNT OF
THE HARSH REALITY OF THE LIFE
THAT OCCURRED TO CALIFORNIA
INDIAN PEOPLE NOT KNOWING THAT
THE TIME IN FOURTH GRADE I CHOSE
MISSION FAMILIES RAY AS MY
PROJECT HAD I HAVE KNOWN I WOULD
HAVE DONE MY OWN TRIBE'S HISTORY
AT IS AS EQUALLY IF NOT MORE
IMPORTANT GIVEN NOW THAT MY OWN
TWO CHILDREN ARE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SUCH PROJECTS
I ALWAYS HAVE THEM DO SOMETHING
THAT RELATES TO CIBULKOVA. OR.
ANY OTHER TRAVEL AFFILIATE. NOW
SO THAT THEY CAN LEARN BUT TO
EDUCATE THEIR FELLOW STUDENTS AS
WELL AS THEIR INSTRUCTOR. THE
PRIDE THAT THEY HAVE TO PRESENT
ABOUT THE CULTURE AND COMMUNITY
MAKES THEM PROUD OF WHO THEY
ARE. WHETHER THE TRUTH IS HARD
HARSH THE TRUTH NEEDS TO BE TOLD
AND BY THE CALIFORNIA INDIAN
TRIBES. WHO HAVE INHERITED THE
RICH HISTORY AND CULTURE. THEY
NEED FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE
OFFICE OF EDUCATION TO CONSIDER
AB ONE SEVEN OH THREE TO
ESTABLISH A TASK FORCE WITH THE
TRIBES LOCAL IN THE REGION. IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO THE FIRST
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. AND THOSE
WHO RESIDE IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA NATIVES HAVE BEEN
RESILIENT AND SURVIVE THE MOST
EXTREME ACTS OF GENOCIDE AND
COLONIZATION. IT'S TIME TO TEACH
THE TRUE HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA.
OF THE HUNDRED AND NINE
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES AND
MORE THAN FIFTY FIVE TRIBES THAT
REMAIN AND RECOGNIZED IT'S
IMPORTANT TO TEACH ABOUT
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE IN ALL
SCHOOLS. HOW INSTRUCTION IS
DEVELOPED AND OFFERED IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO THE TRIBES. WE ARE
EAGER TO SHARE. OUR CULTURE
HISTORY AND OUR COMMUNITY. ALL
TRIBES ARE UNIQUE AND DIVERSE
FROM NORTHERN CENTRAL AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. WE ARE ONLY
ASIANS AND EXERCISE OUR TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY DALY. TO CONTINUE TO
BE SELF RELIANT AND GROW OUR
TRIBAL ECONOMIES. MISSION OF IT
MY HEART IS GOOD. THANK YOU.
YOUR NEXT WITNESS. NOT TO ONE
JOHNNY HERNANDEZ NINE YOU HAVE
IT DOWN. THERE WHO IN OCCUPY.
WITH THE YUCCA. YOU HAVE YOU
DUMP THEM OF GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JOHN HERNANDEZ I HAVE
THE HONOR OF SERVING AS VICE
CHAIRS AND WHILE. I'M HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTEEN OH THREE. WHICH
THEM WELL AS A PROUD SPONSOR. AS
CALIFORNIA OF NATIONS WE EMBODY
MANY UNIQUE SOCIAL CULTURAL
POLITICAL IDENTITIES. OFTEN
CONTESTANT CHALLENGES CHALLENGED
BY FORCES OUTSIDE OUR
GOVERNMENTS AND FAMILIES. FROM A
YOUNG AGE WE FIND OURSELVES
BOUNCING BETWEEN TWO WORLDS. THE
WHATEVER TRIBES IN OUR
ANCESTORS. AND THE WORLD WOULD
COME TO KNOW THROUGH SCHOOL WORK
IN OUR PEERS. DIVISIONS BETWEEN
WHAT WE HAVE NATIVE AMERICANS
HOLD TRUE. AND WHAT WE WERE
TAUGHT IN SCHOOL LEASES
VULNERABLE AND DOUBT. ABOUT OUR
PLACE IN THE STATE. TO MAKE SURE
FUTURE. DO NOT SHARE THAT SAME
PAIN. IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PASSES BILL. AS
GENERATIONS OF MOTHERS AND
FATHERS WITHIN OUR OWN TRIBE.
HAVE LIVED THROUGH VIOLENT
PRESSION OTHER LANGUAGE CULTURE
AND IDENTITY IN SCHOOLS. AND TO
GRASSROOTS APPROACH TO BRIDGES
DIVIDE. AND SAMBAR DINO
COLLABORATION BETWEEN SAM WELL
TRAVEL CITIZENS. AND EDUCATORS
CREATED DECEMBER DINO CITY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. TITLE
SIX INDIAN EDUCATION PROGRAM IN
THE LATE NINETEEN EIGHTIES. THE
PROGRAM HAS ITS ORIGINS IN THE
WORK OF TRAVEL ELDERS FROM SAM
WHILE. WHO FOR DECADES BEFORE
WENT TO SCHOOLS ON THEIR OWN TO
SHARE THEIR CULTURE WITH
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS. BUT
BUILDING RELATIONSHIPS ON A
SCHOOL BY SCHOOL BASIS. THEY
KNEW THAT OF THEIR CHILDREN AND
OTHER NATIVE CHILDREN WITNESS
AUTHENTIC. REPRESENTATIONS OF
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE. IT WOULD HELP
TO AFFIRM THEIR IDENTITIES.
LEADING TO BETTER OUTCOMES IN
CLOSING THE DIVIDE BETWEEN
SCHOOL AND HOME. OUR TRIBE KNEW
THAT DEVELOPING A MORE
SUSTAINABLE APPROACH IS CRITICAL
IN ORDER TO CONTINUE THIS
IMPORTANT WORK. THE FOR THE
STRIDES OF OUR ELDERS FOR YOUNG
FATHERS FROM A RESERVATION.
ASSEMBLY JAMES RAMOS BEING AMONG
THEM BEGAN A COLLABORATION WITH
SALMON DINO CITY. AND COUNTY
SCHOOLS AND CAL STATE SAMBAR
DINO. IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT.
THEY GET TASK FORCE APPROACH
LARGE SCALE FIELD TRIP TO
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS ORGANIZED
FOR A WEEK LONG. CALIFORNIA
INDIAN CULTURE AWARENESS OF
THAT. AND HONOR OF THE STATE'S
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN DAY.
AT THIS EVENT DATA PEOPLE BECAME
THE TEACHERS TO THE STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS LIKE. PRESENTING THE
FACTUAL ACCOUNTS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND CULTURES. I AM
PLEASED TO SAY THAT THIS MODEL
HAS REACHED TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS. TEACHERS AND PARENTS
IN THE TWENTY PLUS YEARS. IT HAS
ALSO PROVEN SO SUCCESSFUL THAT
NOW IS THE TIME FOR TRIBES IN
THE STATE. TO TAKE THE NEXT STEP
TOGETHER TO INTRODUCED THIS
CONCEPT TO ALL CALIFORNIANS.
MANY TRIBES ARE WHERE WE WERE IN
THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES
APPROACHING SCHOOLS
INDIVIDUALLY. RISKING BEING
TURNED AWAY FURTHER DIVIDING AND
FRACTURING IDENTITIES. AB
SEVENTEEN OH THREE CAN
PROPERTIES GOALS AND DISTRICTS
TO OPEN THEIR DOORS. AND MINDS.
TO TRIBES IN THE TRUTH THAT THE
BRING. I ASK FOR YOUR- OF THE-
INDIAN EDUCATION ACT. IN EFFECT
TO CONTINUE THE POSITIVE GOOD
WORK AT THE STATE TO RECONCILE
AND HEAL FROM THE FAST PASS
TREATMENTS OF NATIVE PEOPLE. OF
FULFILLING THE PROMISE FUTURE OF
DIGNITY AND UNDERSTANDING FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. A GROUP I
THINK YOU. THE PROPOSAL THANK
YOU ARE WITH THAT WILL NOW GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH
TO WEIGH IN ON THIS BILL WITH
THEIR SUPPORT SO IF YOU SUPPORT
THE BELMONT TO SPEAK RIGHT NOW
YOU CAN COME UP AND YOU CAN SAY
YOUR NAME IF YOU'RE AFFILIATED
WITH ANY GROUP AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL ONLY IT'S NOT TIME
FOR ANYTHING FURTHER THAN THAT
NAME. POSITION ON IT AFFILIATION
OR YOUR AFFILIATED WITH MEMBER
THE PUBLIC IS FINE- AND YOUR
POSITION. ON THE BILL. HELLO MY
NAME IS EVERY WALK ON OF THE
HONOR OF SERVING AS CHAIRMAN FOR
THE SMALL BATTLES AND UNIONS I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
OH THREE. THANK YOU. HELLO I'M-
HELLO MY NAME IS GAUGE ANAND IS
I'M A YOUTH COMMITTEE MEMBER%
FROM SOME- ABOUT EMISSION
INDIANS. AND I'M A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF AB SEVENTEEN OH
THREE THANK YOU. HUMMING TONES
ON IT ON HOT. HELLO MY NAME IS
HAWK- FROM- USED REMEMBER FROM
THE SENATE WILL BEEN MISSION
INDIANS. AND I SUPPORT AB ONE
SEVEN OH THREE. HI GOOD AT HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JORDAN
REAL HARM TO YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBER FROM SIMILAR MANUMISSION
AND INDIANS AND I'M A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF- AB AB SEVEN ONE OR
THREE ONE SEVEN OH THREE. THANK
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
NICHOLA HERNANDEZ I'M A MEMBER
OF THE YOUTH COMMITTEE OF BENT
SIMO BANISHING INDIANS AND I'M A
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SHANTI
RAMOS I'M A PART OF THESE
COMMITTEE OF THE SEMINOLE TRIBE
AND I SUPPORT AB ONE SEVEN OH
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BLAKE JOHNSON
HAVE HALF A STATEMENT IN A
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TWENTY
THURMAN PROCOL SPONSOR HERE IN
SUPPORT. HELLO MY NAME IS DANIEL
VALDEZ- INFAMOUS MOBILES AND
UNIQUE INDIANS AND I SUPPORT AB
ONE SEVEN ZERO THREE. HELLO MY
NAME IS GLORIA SAYS I AM FROM
THE SUBVENTION INDIANS AND I'M
STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE AB
ONE SEVEN ZERO THREE. MEALWORM
MATONGO CHAU ACCUSE MARVI SO I'M
A TRIBAL MEMBER OF SUPPOSED
FAMILY SAID YOU INDIANS AND I'M
A STRONG SUPPORTER OF AB ONE
SEVEN ZERO THREE. MEANWHILE I'M
GENETICALLY MAHATO I AM A PART
OF THE SUBURBAN OF LEWIS AND
UNIONS AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORTIVE OF AB ONE SEVEN ZERO
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ANABEL HERNANDEZ I AM ME THE
MEMBER OF THE YOUTH COMMITTEE OF
SALMON WILL BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF.
AB SEVENTEEN OH THREE. HELLO
CRAZINESS UNLESS OUT OF
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER BUT ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF BILINGUAL
EDUCATION. BERMAN IS VICTOR
CALDERONE FROM SUBVENTION UNIONS
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVENTEEN OH THREE. HELLO I AM
CAL TITLED COUNSELING FOR CIVIL
OF ANALYSTEN U. INDIANS AND I AM
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN OH
THREE THANK YOU. HI DAVID CANTON
ON BEHALF OF THE VIA HUSBAND OF
KUMEYAAY INDIANS THE BATTLE POMO
OF UPPER LAKE AND THE KOREA
TRIBE IN SUPPORT. HELLO MY NAME
IS AYE ON TO BE HONEST I'M FROM
THE CIVIL BAND OF THE SENATE
INDIANS AND I'M STRONGLY IN.
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN. HELLO
REALIZZATO AND I WAS VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF AB SEVENTEEN OKAY. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
RUSSELL QUATRE ON FROM CIVIL
VENN OF THE CENTURIONS AND THE
CREW HAVE BEEN DIVIDENDS AND- I
AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE FOR
DIRECTIONS FROM THE NORTH FROM
MIDDLE SCHOOL AND I'M IT'S FOUR
OF THE AB WAS. SEVENTEEN OH
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
RON VALENZUELA I MAY TRAVEL
MEMBER OF CIVIL BEEN OF LISTEN
YOU INDIANS AND I'M A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF AB ONE SEVEN ZERO
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS JOY WILLIAMS A MEMBER
OF THE CHOIRS ARE NEWER PEOPLE
KERN VALLEY INTO COMMUNITY HERE-ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE- PROJECT INTENDED
THOUSANDS OF NATIVES. AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN OH THREE
TO CALIFORNIA YOU NEED EDUCATION
ACT. GATHER THOUSANDS OF
SIGNATURES AND IF I GOT A LOT OF
CALLS FROM US. SO THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS DONNA POST
IMAGE- TRIBAL MEMBER FENCIBLE
BALANCE WHEN THE INDIANS AND I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB ONE
SEVEN ZERO THREE THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M CÁC CASTRO
ADMITTED NAY AND CHICANA AND
WITH THE- LA CITY COUNTY NATIVE
AMERICAN INDIAN COMMISSION. AS
WELL AS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE VOTE
PROJECT AND WE'RE ALL IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SEVENTEEN OH THREE
THANK YOU. IT'S ALSO GONNA KIANA
KONG CALVIN HEDRICK I AM AMOUNT
MIGHT BE PERSON- FROM UP HERE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SIERRAS. AND
I'M HERE TODAY REPRESENTING- NOT
ONLY MY PEOPLE BUT- THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE A PROJECT IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
OH THREE THANK YOU. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FRANK
MOLINA ON BEHALF A COUPLE OF THE
SPONSORS OF THE MEASURE SALMON
WILL BAND OF MISSION INDIANS IN
THE SENATE IS SPANISH EMISSIONS
YES THANK YOU. CHARMERS JOHN
LINGER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. SEEING
NO OTHER. SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
. SEEING OPPOSITION WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE- I'LL
JUST SPEAK FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
MR ALMOST- WHY THINK IS A GOOD
BILL IS BECAUSE IT HELPS
TEACHERS. OF EDUCATE KIDS THIS
IS A CLASSROOM TEACHER LISTEN I
DIDN'T HAVE I DON'T HAVE OF THE
KNOWLEDGE OF. WHERE WHERE WHERE
THE NATIVE AMERICANS WERE IN MY
AREA AND THE NAMES AND ALL THOSE
THINGS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
MOBILE THAT'S WHAT YOUR BILL
TRIES TO. TRIES TO PULL TOGETHER
AND THIS COMES OUT OF THAT
HEARING THAT WE HAD IN AWHILE
AWHILE BACK WE ARE HEARING AND
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES- THE
NATIVE AMERICAN. COMMUNITY FACES
IN IN AND WE TALKED ABOUT. WITH
THE AMERICANS SHOULD ALSO NOT
NATIVE AMERICAN STUDENTS RIGHT
AND HOW DO WE EDUCATE THEM. AND
I REMEMBER SAYING WELL WE DON'T
KNOW WE ONCE ONE THING COMING
OUT OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION. BECAUSE THERE'S SO
MANY DIFFERENT YOU KNOW IT
NATIVE AMERICAN GROUPS ACROSS
THE STATE THAT HAVE
HISTORICALLY. BEEN LOCATED AND
READY PLACES RIGHT SO IT IS SO
WHAT THISSEEKS TO DO. IS TO GET
LOCAL KNOWLEDGE TO LOCALS RIGHT.
AS SACRAMENTO'S NOT HAVE THEIR
VERSION OF THIS YEAR AT THE
LOCALS GOING TO BETTER JOBS
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THEIR HISTORY
RIGHT THEY PASS IT DOWN THEY
SHARED. AND SO I THINK THIS IS A
REAL REAL GOOD EFFORT THAT CAN
HELP TEACHERS OF STUDENTS SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORT HERE
TODAY IS THERE ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO WISH TO
SPEAK. EARLY THANK YOU SIR I
JUST THANK ASSEMBLY ROBERT RINGS
. FOR US AGAIN AND THIS
COMMITTEE AND THANKS ALL THE
pTRAVELED FAR AND WIDE TO MAKE
THEIR VOICES HEARD- I THINK THIS
IS AN EXCELLENT BILL. IT'S
ESPECIALLY CRUCIAL TO HAVE THE
INPUT OF THE LOCAL TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES. AND IN PUTTING THAT
CAN EDUCATION CERTAINLY. I CAN.
RELATE TO THE STORY OF ONE OF
OUR SPEAKERS SAID TO SAME THING
WITH. OUR DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
RIGHT WHERE PEOPLE ASSUME ALSO
JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE ONE TYPE
VISION WE'RE ALL THE SAME TIME
VISION. I THINK THERE'S A
PERVASIVE MYTH THAT. OTHERS AYE
ONE TYPE OF NATIVE CIVILIZATION
THAT EXISTED IN EVERY ONE OF
PROBABLY THE SAME. I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT AND THIS IS
INCREDIBLE I THINK THAT WILL
HELP. CORRECT OUR HISTORY AND
ALSO TEACH SO MANY PEOPLE MUCH
MORE ABOUT THE BRILLIANT.
HISTORY OF THE CIVILIZATIONS I
CALL CALIFORNIA HOME WAY BEFORE
AND THE SETTLERS. CROSSES YOU TO
COME HERE I WOULD LOVE TO BE OF
COURSE THAT IS A CO AUTHOR TO
THIS EFFORT AND- ALSO AND STRONG
FAVORITE YOUR BILL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MISTER BENNETT. AFTER
SPENDING TWENTY FIVE YEARS
TEACHING HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS I
JUST WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF THE CHAIR- HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHERS ALL TEACHERS WILL
BENEFIT- MORE THEY. LEARN FROM
FROM THE TRAVEL MEMBERS THANK
YOU. A YOU. STALI DOLLY. I THANK
YOU ALL FOR COMING HERE TODAY
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
TESTIMONIES AND THE STORIES THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR WHEN THIS IS
IMPLEMENTED WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE
NOW IN OUR SCHOOLS AND HOPEFULLY
IN YEARS TO COME YOU'LL BE BACK
HERE AGAIN TO TELL US THAT THIS
WORKS AND IT WENT WELL SO I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT I LIKE TO MOVE
THE BILL. THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED
AND SECONDED- THAT THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS- DO
YOU WISH TO CLOSE MYSTERON THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR-
YOUR COMMENTS TO AND IT WILL
START TO PAVE THE WAY TO GET
THAT MUCH NEEDED- FACTUAL-
CULTURAL CURRICULUM INTO THE
HANDS. OF ALL STUDENTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE TESTIMONY AND
YOUR SUPPORT NOW WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEAVE FOR
AGREEING TO COME ON AS A CO
AUTHOR WOULD. UP MANY OTHER CO
AUTHORS IT WOULD LIKE TO JOIN UP
FROM THIS COMMITTEE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD AND I WOULD. BE
DELIGHTED TO EARN YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU ARE WITH
THAT LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. O'DONNELL A HERE BUT ON A
PRESENT VALUE. VALLEY PRESENT
BENNETT. SENATE PRESIDENT CHEN
CAN PRESENT LEAD. LEAVE PRESENT
MCCARTY QUIRK-SILVA. WE DO THAT
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM-
THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AB SEVENTEEN OH THREE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED YOU
APPROPRIATIONS BUT DONALD HI
DONALD I DALLI. DALLI II BENNETT
. SENATE AYE CHAN. CAN I LEAVE
LEAI RT QUIRK-SILVA. THE BILL
HAS FIVE VOTES IT IS OUTSIDE
IT'S PAST THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER DARK THANK YOU THANK YOU
I JUST WANT TO- DON'T KNOW THE
PRESENCE OF MR CHEN- OUR NEW
EDUCATION MEMBER DO YOU WANNA
COME FORWARD SO WE CAN SWEAR YOU
IN. WELL JOB YOU WANT LATER ALL
RIGHT- WITH THAT BUT WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE. WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PRESENCE HERE. I WOULD HAVE
TO CHECK. THANK YOU THANK YOU
YOUR SPEAKER. WELL DONE. WE'RE
GONNA GO TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO. WHICH IS AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN. BY SOME REMEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH. ARE YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY. TWO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES FOR EACH
ONE FOR EACH- WITNESSES TO
WITNESSES TO INTO. FILE ITEM
NUMBER. TWO GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN BIRTH AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN REQUIRE THE
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TO ALLOCATE FUNDING
UPON APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THE PURCHASE OF
K. THROUGH TWELVE STANDARDS
ALIGNED INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS
IN VISUAL AND PERFORMING ARTS
AND WORLD LANGUAGES THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS STANDARDS
PROVIDE GUIDANCE TOWARDS
ACHIEVING A COMMON GOAL WHICH IS
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS STUDENTS
FULLY PARTICIPATE IN A RICH AND
WELL ROUNDED ARTS EDUCATION. THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION ADOPTED
REVISED CONTENT STANDARDS AND
VISUAL AND PERFORMING ARTS AND
WORLD LANGUAGES IN TWENTY
NINETEEN ADOPTED REVISED
CURRICULUM FRAMEWORKS IN TWENTY
TWENTY AND NEW INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS FOR KINDERGARTEN AND
GRADES ONE TO EIGHT INCLUSIVE IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN SIX TO PROVIDE CARE
THROUGH SCHOOL AT TWELVE SCHOOLS
WITH ONETIME PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING FOR THE PURCHASE
OF THESE INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS. FOCUSING ON SYSTEMS
THAT ENSURE ALL STUDENTS HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO LEARN THE ARTS
IS ESSENTIAL FOR IN ENSURING
EQUAL ACCESS TO THE ARTS THESE
OPPORTUNITIES INCLUDE SYSTEMIC
INSTRUCTIONAL RESOURCES SUCH AS
ACCESS TO CERTIFIED ARTS
EDUCATORS. EXPANDED COURSE
OFFERINGS IN THE FIVE ARTS
DISCIPLINES AN ADEQUATE TIME
SPACE MATERIALS FOR ARTS
LEARNING. THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
STANDARDS PROVIDE GUIDANCE
TOWARDS ACHIEVING A COMMON GOAL
WHICH IS THAT ALL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS FULLY PARTICIPATE IN A
RICH WELL ROUNDED ARTS
EDUCATION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND WITH ME
HERE TODAY TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL I HAVE JOHN BYRNE.
IMMEDIATE PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA MUSIC EDUCATORS
ASSOCIATION AND REBEKAH ESTES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LANGUAGE TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
UNIVERSITY LOCKERROOM THE MIKE
BUTTON. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRPERSON AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M JOHN BYRNE AND THE
IMMEDIATE PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA MUSIC EDUCATORS
ASSOCIATION AND AS SUCH I ALSO
SERVE ON THE POLICY COUNCIL FOR
CREATE CALIFORNIA BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY I'M A HIGH SCHOOL
BAND DIRECTOR AT HOMESTEAD HIGH
SCHOOL IN CUPERTINO CALIFORNIA
MAYBE USE ON MY BAND ON TV IN
THE TWENTY NINETEEN ROSE PARADE
. CMEA MEMBERS ARE MUSIC
TEACHERS PROVIDING MUSIC
INSTRUCTION TO STUDENTS IN OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. I'M HERE TODAY
REQUESTING YOUR SUPPORT AND A
YES VOTE ON AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN THE BENEFITS OF AN ARTS
EDUCATION WHICH INCLUDE THE
DISCIPLINES OF MUSIC. DANCE
MEDIA ARTS THEATER AND VISUAL
ARTS ALONG WITH RULING WHICH IS
OUR MANY THAT INCLUDE FOSTERING
CRITICAL THINKING CREATIVITY
COLLABORATION COMMUNICATION AND
INNOVATION SKILLS NECESSARY FOR
PREPARING OUR STUDENTS. TO
SUCCEED IN THEIR COLLEGE AND
CAREER READINESS AS WELL AS
SUCCEEDING IN AN INFORMATION
BASED TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
WORKPLACE AND GLOBAL ECONOMY.
CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY NINETEEN
ARTS STANDARDS IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ARTS EDUCATION FRAMEWORK
ADOPTED BY THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION. PROVIDES A STRONG
FOUNDATION FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
OF ARTISTIC COMPETENCIES BY ALL
STUDENTS AS WELL AS PROVIDING
OUR TEACHERS WITH GUIDANCE AND
TOOLS NECESSARY. TO ENSURE
QUALITY AND EFFECTIVE VISUAL AND
PERFORMING ARTS INSTRUCTION TO
ALL OF OUR CHILDREN. AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN PROPOSES
PROVIDING THE NECESSARY
RESOURCES TO ENSURE STUDENTS
HAVE ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
STANDARDS ALIGNED INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS DIGITAL PLATFORMS AND
INSTRUCTION TEACHERS WOULD BE
GIVEN THE TOOLS AND INFORMATION
FOR PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES. ON HOW BEST TO
TEACH ALL OF THE ARTS EDUCATION
DISCIPLINES EVERY STUDENT HAS A
RIGHT TO A WELL ROUNDED
EDUCATION INCLUDING
OPPORTUNITIES AND ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY ARTS EDUCATION. AGAIN
PLEASE VOTE YES ON AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON TEAR DOWN ON MEMBERS
OF THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS REBECCA ESTES I HAVE
BEEN TEACHING SPANISH AT THE
HIGH SCHOOL AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEVEL FOR FIFTEEN YEARS.
AND I'M THE ADVOCACY CHAIR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA LANGUAGE TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION. CLT IS MEMBERS
INCLUDE OVER TWO THOUSAND
LANGUAGE EDUCATOR SERVING
STUDENTS FROM KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH THE UNIVERSITY LEVEL. ON
BEHALF OF THE L. T. A. WOULD
LIKE TO THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH FOR SPONSORING
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. AND A YES VOTE
ON THE BILL. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN I CO CHAIRED THE WORLD
LANGUAGES CURRICULUM FRAMEWORK
COMMITTEE TO DEVELOP THE
FRAMEWORK TO SUPPORT EDUCATORS
IN TEACHING THE RECENTLY REVISED
STANDARDS. TO GATHER THE NEW
STANDARDS IN PRIMARK PROVIDED A
PATHWAY FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS TO DEVELOP MULTILINGUAL
PROFICIENCY. AND CAREER
READINESS. BECAUSE THE STANDARDS
REPRESENT A SIGNIFICANT SHIFT IN
INSTRUCTIONAL APPROACHES
EDUCATORS NEED ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES SUCH AS THE
PROGRAMS PROVIDED BY THE
CALIFORNIA SUBJECT MATTER
PROGRAM. AFTER PREVIOUS
ADOPTIONS OF REVISED CONTENT
STANDARDS IN OTHER DISCIPLINES
FUNDING WAS PROVIDED FOR THE
PURCHASE OF STANDARD ALIGNED
MATERIALS AND FOR ASSOCIATED
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT. VISUAL
AND PERFORMING ARTS AND WORLD
LANGUAGES ARE CRITICAL CONTENT
AREAS FOR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
REFLECTED IN THEIR STATUS AS
REQUIREMENTS FOR BOTH HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION. AND UC AND
CSU ADMISSION IN ADDITION A
WORLD LANGUAGE INSTRUCTION HAS
BEEN SHOWN TO IMPROVE STUDENT
COGNITIVE FUNCTIONING SUPPORT
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING
PREPARES STUDENTS TO SUCCEED TO
SUCCEED IN A GLOBAL ECONOMY. I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN TO ENSURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
HAVE EQUITABLE ACCESS TO THEIR
EDUCATION THANK YOU. GREAT THANK
YOU NOW GO TO OTHERS IN THE ROOM
THAT ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
YOU MAY COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KATHY LYNCH
REPRESENTING CREATE CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA LANGUAGE
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR HEALTH PHYSICAL
EDUCATION RECREATION AND DANCE
IN SUPPORT. ASSEMBLY ARE PEOPLE
COMMITTEE- THIS IS TRAVIS ALLEN-
VICE PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA MUSIC
EDUCATION- I SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MARTHA'S YEAR AGO CITY
AS REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
MUSIC EDUCATORS ASSOCIATION AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. SEEING
NO OPPOSITION TO THE BILL WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY COMMENTS FROM ANY OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. BEEN MOVED BY
THE VICE CHAIR. WE HAVE A SECOND
BY MISTER MISTER LEAH SECONDED
RIGHT ARM BUT YOU MAY CLOSE AYE
RESPECTIVELY I'M SURE MOST OF
WHICH YOU MAKERS SAYING THAT-
YOU DON'T WANT ME TO SING THE
CLASS BUT SHE'LL SHE'LL TEACHES
HOW NECESSARY. THAT WAS. THAT
WOULD TRUE. YES I. ASK YOUR-
OKAY THEY WILL TAKE THAT- WITH
THAT- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL APPRECIATE ABOUT THE- AND
FILE ITEM TO AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL BY
DONAL I VALLEY. ALII BENNETT
BENNETT I CHEN CHEN I LEE LEE
AYE MCCARTY QUIRK-SILVA. I LOVE
THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTES WHO IS
OUT THANK YOU JOHN. THE JOB YOUR
WITNESSES THANK YOU I WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO A FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB EIGHTEEN TEN MR LEVINE.
NO SORRY. OKAY SO HE WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON THEN TO FILE ITEM FIVE
MISTER CUNNINGHAM. AND WE'RE
CALLING PEOPLE NOW SO. YOU WANT
YOUR BILL HEARD SHE GOT HERE-
WE'RE GOING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX THIS DAVIES. NOT HERE. FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN. MR GABRIEL.
NOT PRESENT. FILE ITEM THERE
EIGHT MISTER COOPER. WELL. AS
THE CHAIR I HAVE THE PREROGATIVE
OF. YOU GUYS WANT TO DO. THIS IS
THEIR DAY THEY DON'T GET ANOTHER
DAY OR SO.
SORRY.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM AS FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB EIGHTEEN NINETY
THREE THAT'S WHY I DON'T
REMEMBER FIVE YOU MAY PROCEED
WHEN READY. MEMBERS. EIGHTEEN
NINETY THREE FIRST LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR ALL THEIR HARD
WORK ON THE BILL OF ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS OF
COURSE A DURING THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO SCHOOL YEAR SCHOOLS
ACROSS THE STATE WERE HIT HARD
WITH TEACHER ABSENCES DUE TO
COVER NINETEEN WE ALL KNOW THAT
ALSO COINCIDED WITH THE PRE
EXISTING SUBSTITUTE TEACHER
SHORTAGE. FOR EXAMPLE IN SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN SCHOOL YEAR THE CTC
ISSUED MORE THAN TWENTY THOUSAND
SUBSTITUTE TEACHING PERMITS BUT
IN NINETEEN TWENTY ISSUED
SLIGHTLY MORE THAN FIFTEEN
THOUSAND. AB EIGHTEEN NINETY
THREE TEMPORARILY WAIVES THE
BASIC SKILLS REQUIREMENT FOR
APPLICANTS APPLICANTS SEEKING AN
EMERGENCY THIRTY DAY SUBSTITUTE
PERMIT. AND IT DOES SO ONLY
UNTIL JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
. FROM MARCH TWENTY TWENTY TO
AUGUST TWENTY ONE THE CDC
ALLOWED SUBSTITUTE PERMIT
APPLICANTS TO DEFER TAKING THE
C. BEST THIS BILL EXTENDS THE
SAME FLEXIBILITY IT WAS IN PLACE
FOR MAJORITY THE PANDEMIC TO
MAKE SURE SCHOOLS CAN CATCH UP.
AND GET ENOUGH SUBSTITUTES TO
FILL THEIR CLASSROOMS AS NEEDED
. AND THAT'S IT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR ABOUT GREAT. NOT TO HAVE
ANY WITNESSES NO WITNESSES. AND
NO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
THERE ARE OTHERS IN SUPPORT YOU
MAY COME FORWARD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON DOROTHY JOHNSON WITH
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU. SEEING OTHERS IN SUPPORT
THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED. AND
SECONDED BY. MR CHAN OKAY- ARE
THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
. SEE NO OPPOSITION WILL BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS READY TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS NO COMMENTS READY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE YOU MAY
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
OF SIXTY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM FIVE AB EIGHTEEN
NINETY THREE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FOR DONALD. I
O'DONNELL I DALLI. DALLI I'D
BENNETT HI SENATE AYE GEN. CAN I
LEAVE. LEAI MCCARTY QUIRK-SILVA
. BILLS FIVE ALSO IS OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WITH THAT WE'RE
STILL WAITING FOR AUTHORS.
WHY DON'T WE TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR NOW.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT- MISTER LEE MOTIONS AND-
MISTER BENNETT SECONDS. YEAH SO
. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THIS
CALL THE ROLL ON THE THIS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
SIX THE MOTION AS YOU PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ASSEMBLY HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE. THE DONALD I
DON'T KNOW WHY DALLI. DALLI I'D
BENNETT. BENNETT I. CAN SEND I
LEAVE. LEAVE I MCCARTY
QUIRK-SILVA. I LOVE THE BILL THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS FIVE VOTE
SO IT IS IT IS OUT.
WALKED IN. MISTER COOPER.
WINDERMERE MISTER COOPER. AS
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB TWO ZERO EIGHT
EIGHT. YOU MAY RECEIVE ONE READY
MISTER COOPER. IN THE WEST END
OF THE L. USUALLY WHAT MEMBERS
DO. A. I SEE A GOOD MOOD TODAY
MISTER CHAIRMAN GOOD TO SEE YOU
TO. OKAY AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
LET ME BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS I THINK
THEY MAKE THE BILL BETTER. AB
TWENTY EIGHTY EIGHT AT TWENTY
EIGHT MY GLASSES ON. TWENTY
EIGHT AGREED THE CALIFORNIA
PILOT PAID INTERNSHIP PROGRAM
OPERATED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION. THIS PILOT
PROGRAM PROVIDE GRANTS LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES THAT MAKE OR
HAVE CREATED LOCAL PRIVATE
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS.
PARTNERSHIP INTERNSHIP PROGRAMS
THESE PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS WILL
PROVIDE OUR STUDENTS WITH HANDS
ON EXPERIENCE IN CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION FIELDS AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY PROVIDE THEM
WITH A WAY TO. HELP SUPPORT
THEMSELVES THEIR FAMILIES AND
THEIR COMMUNITIES. PAID
INTERNSHIPS PROVIDE BUSINESSES
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS OUR
WORKFORCE NEEDS TO PROVIDE
STUDENTS WITH AN OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN A TRADE OR PROFESSION.
NUMEROUS STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT
POSITIVE EFFECTS ON STUDENTS TO
PARTICIPATE IN CTE PROGRAMS
ACADEMIC AND OTHERWISE. EVERY
DOLLAR WE SPEND ON THIS PROGRAM
WILL HELP BETTER TRAIN OUR
STUDENTS AND CONNECT THEM WITH
CAREERS IN TRANSIT EDUCATION
CONSTRUCTION. HEALTH CARE AND
OTHER IMPORTANT CAREER FIELDS.
HERE TO TESTIFY SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TWENTY
THURMAN THE SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY
EIGHTY EIGHT IT'S PETER CALLOUS
DIRECTOR OF CAREER. COLLEGE AND
TECHNICAL TRANSITION DIVISION OF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EDUCATION
. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN DONALD
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR LETTING ME TESTIFIED
TODAY MY NAME IS P. CALLOUS ON
THE DIVISION DIRECTOR OF THE
COLLEGE AND CAREER. TRANSITION
DIVISION AT CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
EDUCATION THEM TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT
PUBLIC CONSTRUCTION TONY
THURMOND. AB TWO ZERO EIGHT
EIGHT THE CALIFORNIA PUT PILOT
PAID INTERNSHIP PROGRAM ALIGNS
WITH CURRENT GOLDEN PROGRAMS ARE
BEING ADMINISTERED BY THE CREEK
COLLEGE TRANSITION OF ASIAN.
THESE PAID INTERNSHIPS ALLOW
BUSINESSES TO PARTNER WITH THEIR
LOCAL HIGH SCHOOLS TO DEVELOP
STUDENTS CAREER READY SKILLS BY
LEARNING A TRADE OR PROFESSION.
AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THEIR AND THEIR COMMUNITY.
ADDRESS OUR COMMUNITY'S
WORKFORCE NEEDS PAID INTERNSHIPS
WILL ALSO SAYS STUDENTS DECIDE
ON WHETHER THEY WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE PURSUING A CAREER IN
THE CAREER PATHWAY FOCUS OF THE
RESPECTIVE. INTERNSHIP WHERE
SCHOOLS ARE PROVIDING PAID
INTERNSHIPS INNER CITY STUDENTS
WE'RE SEEING GREAT RESULTS IT IS
EXAMPLE ARE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP ACADEMY TEAM IS
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH. MARRIOTT
RESORTS ON A PAID INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM THAT WAS INITIATED IN
THE COACHELLA VALLEY NOW IS X.
BEING EXPANDED TO OTHER REGIONS
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AB TWO
ZERO EIGHT EIGHT WILL ALSO
ASSIST WITH THE EXPANSION OF
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING YOUTH
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS. THE
BEGAN WITH OUR NINE MULTI CRAFT
CORE CURRICULUM PARTNERSHIP
CATANESE KNOWN AS THE M. C.
THREES THERE THE EDUCATIONAL
FOUNDATION FOR THE BUILDING
TRADES WHICH IS DESIGNED TO HELP
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS CHOOSE AND
SUCCEED. IN AN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM THE CALIFORNIA CAREER IN
COLLEGE TRANSITION DIVISION
TEAM. AT CD IS NOW WORKING WITH
THE DIVISION OF APPRENTICESHIP
STANDARDS TO EXPAND OUR YOUTH
APPRENTICESHIPS IN FIVE OTHER
INDUSTRY SECTORS THAT AVE HIGH
WAGE AND HIGH DEMAND WORKFORCE
OPPORTUNITIES. PASSED THE BILL
WILL HELP OUR STUDENTS BECOME
PART OF CALIFORNIA SKILLED
WORKFORCE IN INJECT MUCH MORE
INCOME IN FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TESTIFIED TODAY I'M
HAPPY TO ADDRESS AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AT APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU I SEE NO OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT. ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT
YOU COME FORWARD TO THE
MICROPHONE STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY. SEEING NO OTHERS.
INSIST THERE'S ONE I BELIEVE.
MATT PATTON CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU A SINGLE OTHERS IN SUPPORT
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL SINGLE OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL WILL BRING BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS FROM
ANY OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ISTER DOLLY. TO THE AUTHOR SO
I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS BILL
ACTUALLY BUT- I DO HAVE SOME
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS ON MY VERY
RURAL AREAS THAT WE DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE I'M- THE DENIES
IT SAYS THAT THAT WERE DENIED
LIKE JOB SHADOWING AND ONE TIME
EVENTS. SO I I'D LIKE TO WORK
WITH YOU IF I COULD ON THIS BILL
AND THE SPONSOR TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR RULE AREAS ARE NOT. CUT
OUT BECAUSE IT IS ACTUALLY
REALLY DIFFICULT TO FIND A
CAREER TECHNICAL- LIKE A
MECHANIC OR SOMEBODY THAT'S
WILLING TO TAKE WILLING TO TAKE
ON A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT. I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THOSE THESE
DOLLARS IF ALLOCATED DON'T. WE
ARE CUT OUT OF THAT. AND WE'LL
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S SOME
SPECIFIC. MAYBE SOME EXEMPTIONS
FOR SCHOOLS TO HAVE A HARD TIME
FINDING WORK FORCE. CLOSE TO
THEM. IT WILL WORK WITH YOU
OBVIOUSLY IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
EVERYONE ESPECIALLY THE NORTHERN
REGION SO. I WOULD BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO OKAY THANK YOU. GREAT I
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER COMMENTS.
TO MR CALLACE YOU HAD A CD EIGHT
CD. THERE AYE OKAY YOU SEE THAT
A STRONG WORK FORCE ON IT. YES I
WANT TO COMMENT ON THAT NO THANK
YOU. OKAY LET'S LOOK TO THE-
WITH THAT WELL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE WOULD DO WE HAVE A
MOTION YET. WE DID. THIS. WE DID
NOT KNOW MR LEE WE DID NOT HAVE
A MOTION MISTER BENNETT HAS
MOVED THIS DOLLY SECONDS- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WAY TO CLOSE-
YEAH GOING CLOSER. THAT'S
POLITICAL IS STANDING YES WE ARE
I CAN OF THE MICROPHONE SO. SO
WHAT YOU'RE CLOSE. OKAY
YESTERDAY VOTE. FILE ITEM EIGHT
A. B. TWO ZERO EIGHT EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS DONALD BY THE
DONALD HIGH VALLEY VALLEY I'D
BENNETT BENNETT AYE CHEN CAN I
LEAVE. LEAI MCCARTY QUIRK-SILVA
I LOVE. THAT BISHOPRICS YOUR- IT
IS FIVE OH TOURISM THANK YOU.
GREAT WE'RE GONNA GO TO MISS
GARCIA. IS NEXT I KNOW MISTER
WAS WAITING- MISS GARCIA HAS-
EIGHTY S. FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY FOUR I MISS
GARCIA YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY THANK YOU WANT TO START
OFF BY ACCEPTING COMMITTEE MM
AND SUGGEST THAT ON PAGE FIVE OF
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND
THINKING YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THIS BILL. AB TWENTY
ONE TWENTY FOUR WHICH WOULD
ESTABLISH THE PEOPLE SUPPORT
TRAINING TRAINING PROGRAM THIS
PROGRAM WILL ENCOURAGE LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CHARTER SCHOOLS
AND COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
TO APPLY FOR GRANTS TO FUND FOR
PEER SUPPORT TRAINING PROGRAMS
READ MORE MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES FOR NINE TO TWELVE
STUDENTS I'M GONNA KEEP MY
COMMON SHORT I KNOW HOW LONG
IT'S AND THAT THIS IS A WINNER
OF BROUGHT UP A LOT OF YEARS
AGO. ON A AND THE PANDEMIC
DERAIL THAT WORK BUT WE SEE IT I
NEEDED EVEN MORE SO NOW AND I
HAVE A YOUNG STUDENT WHO
INSPIRED THIS BILL WHO WILL BE
RIGHT WITH THE SHODDY. FROM MY
DISTRICT GREAT. YOU MAY PROCEED. A UNITED PROBABLY ADDED YEAH.
CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW OKAY THANK
YOU A GOODAFTERNOON MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND CHAIRS
MOVEMENT-O'DONNELL- I STAND HERE
TODAY AS A SOPHOMORE UC BERKELEY
STUDENT A PROUD A CHILD OF
IMMIGRANTS FROM MEXICO AND
ALUMNI OF DOWNEY HIGH SCHOOL FOR
THE FIFTEENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
AND AS A SWIMMER GARCIA SAID THE
WINNER OF THERE OUGHT TO BE A
LAW CONTESTS WHAT IS TODAY THE
PEOPLE SUPPORT TRAINING PROGRAM
AB. TWENTY ONE TWENTY FOUR. I
PROBABLY DROVE OUT HERE FROM
BERKELEY THIS AFTERNOON TO
SUPPORT AND JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA TO BE HEARD AND
SEEN TODAY AND ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. BEING A FIRST
GENERATION MEXICAN MEXICAN
AMERICAN WHAT THE LACK OF
SUPPORT FROM MY FAMILY DUE TO
CULTURAL BARRIERS AND SCHOOL
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES I
PERSONALLY STRUGGLED WITH
ANXIETY AND DEPRESSION. THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION STATES
THAT DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY ARE
THE LEADING CAUSES OF ILLNESS
AMONG ADOLESCENTS. SUICIDE IS
THE FOURTH LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH AMONG FIFTEEN TO NINETEEN
YEAR OLDS. ASSUME EVEN STATED
THE PERCEPTION THAT ONE HAS TO
BE PERFECT IN EVERY ACADEMIC CO
CURRICULAR SOCIAL ENDEAVOR.
MANIFESTS ITSELF INTO A
DEMORALIZATION ALIENATION AND
THE CONDITION OF ANXIETY AND
DEPRESSION. SO WE SEE THAT THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
IMPLEMENTED WE NEED A STRONGER
SYSTEM AND TO ALLOW STUDENTS WHO
THEMSELVES EXPERIENCE OF THESE
ISSUES TO FILL THAT ROLE. IS ONE
OF THE BEST THINGS WE CAN DO SO
I KINDLY URGE YOU TODAY TO VOTE
YES ON THIS BILL AND SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY GARCIA AND I TO- MAKE
HISTORY AND TO LEAD A MOVEMENT
WITH THIS THANK YOU. GREAT VERY
WELL DONE THANK A TEACHER
PARAMOUNT HIGH SCHOOL. NOT FAR
FROM DOWNEY HIGH SCHOOL VERY
CLOSE- ARE WITH THAT ARE THERE
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT FROM
THE PUBLIC. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LEE ANCILLARY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL COUNSELORS
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SEEING OTHERS IN
SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL SAYING NO OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS REMAIN
ANY OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THEN MOVED AND SECONDED. ARE YOU
MAY CLOSE I THANK YOU JUST WANT
TO BE CLEAR THIS IS JUST A PIECE
OF THE PUZZLE AS WE ADDRESS
STUDENTS MENTAL HEALTH AND I
APPRECIATE AND I VOTE. US
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM TEN AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY FOUR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL I
O'DONNELL I'D VALLEY. VALLEY I'D
BENNETT BENNETT I SENT. CAN I
LEAVE LEE I MCCARTY QUIRK-SILVA
. I THOSE BLESSED FIVE ALSO IS
OUT AND VERY WELL DONE YOUR
WITNESS. THANK YOU. WELL DONE. I
WILL NEXT HEAR FROM MR WOULD
EVEN. EVEN WAITING AGAIN ABOUT
HER. A LITTLE KNOWN FACT MR WHEN
I WENT TO THE SAME HIGH SCHOOL.
WE DID. I DON'T REMEMBER HOW
MANY YEARS APART WE WERE AND I
DON'T THINK WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT THAT BUT- OKAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. YOU'RE HAPPY TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY FOURTEEN. AS SOMEONE
WHOSE PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WHO
PENNED PERSON BEEN EVACUATED FOR
MY HOME MULTIPLE TIMES I KNOW
HOW IMPORTANTIT IS TO BE
PREPARED. UNFORTUNATELY WITH
CLIMATE CHANGE WE'VE EXPERIENCED
MORE AND MORE NATURAL DISASTERS
SUCH AS WILDFIRES AND FLOODS AND
SADLY WE ARE EXPERIENCING HUMAN
CAUSE TRAGEDIES SUCH AS AN ACT
OF VIOLENCE ON A SCHOOL CAMPUS
OR AT THE DISASTROUS CHEMICAL
SPILL. AB TWENTY EIGHT FOURTEEN
WOULD AUTHORIZE A MILLION
DOLLARS AVAILABLE FOR
COMPETITIVE EMERGENCY PLANNING
GRANTS TO HELP LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES PRIORITIZING THESE
AWARDS FOR ELEAZAR FACE THE
GREATEST RISK OF OR HAVE LESS
CAPACITY TO PREPARE FOR
EMERGENCIES THE BILL WOULD
PROVOKE PROMOTE THE SAFETY AND
WELL BEING OF STUDENTS AND
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES DURING AN
EMERGENCY. THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
COLLABORATION BETWEEN EMERGENCY
PERSONNEL AND ELEAZAR TO BE BEST
PREPARED FOR EMERGENCIES HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS DR STEVE
HERRINGTON SUPERINTENDENT FOR
CINEMA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND DEB CUBAN
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE HI A
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. THANK
YOU WITNESSES. AND GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS STEVE HARRINGTON COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT FOR CINEMA
COUNTY. AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
FOURTEEN. THE BILL SPONSORED BY
SOME WOMEN WOULD. IT WOULD MAKE
AVAILABLE THE FUNDING FOR
SCHOOLS FOR BETTER NATURAL
DISASTER PREPAREDNESS. I SPEAK
FROM EXPERIENCE. A FITNESS
CALIFORNIA EDUCATOR FOR FIFTY
ONE YEARS. I'VE GONE THROUGH FOR
NATURAL DISASTER FIRES TO
FLOODS. EARTHQUAKE SO I TELL YOU
BASED ON THOSE EXPERIENCES AND
THE PANDEMIC. THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY. ORDINATED SERVICES IT
IS ESSENTIAL FOR PUBLIC SCHOOLS
. MANY COUNTY OFFICES IN
DISTRICTS INCLUDING MY OWN HAVE
ALREADY TAKEN THIS WORK ON.
VOLUNTARILY HOWEVER MORE NEEDS
TO BE DONE. FROM COMING UP WITH
A CONTINGENCY PLAN AND SAFETY
MEASURES FOR WILDFLOWER FIRES
AND FLOODS HEAT WAVES POWER SHUT
OFFS STAYING ON TOP OF COOLEY
PROTECTIVE MEASURES. LOCAL
EDUCATION EDUCATION AGENCIES
BECOME KEY PARTNERS IN KEEPING
OUR COMMUNITY SAFE AND HEALTHY.
SINCE THEN PRESIDENT SERIES OF
MASSIVE WILDFIRES DESTROYED MORE
THAN FIVE THOUSAND HOMES IN
SONOMA COUNTY THE STAFF AT THE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION HAS
BEEN IN THE STATE OF REGULAR
COLLABORATION WITH OUR COUNTY
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
PREVIOUSLY SUCH DISASTERS
OCCURRED ROUGHLY ONCE IN A
GENERATION. IN OUR COMMUNITIES
BUT THANKS IN PART TO CLIMATE
CHANGE WHICH IS INCREASE DROUGHT
AND THE SEVERITY OF WILDFIRES WE
HAVE EXPERIENCED AS I SAID
EARLIER. FOR MASSIVE WILDLAND
BLAZES SINCE TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
AND WE'VE ENTERED INTO A MORE
INSTRUCTIONAL LOSS IN OUR COUNTY
WITH THE FORTY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
OF OVER TWELVE HUNDRED SCHOOL
DAYS. TAKEN FOR EXEMPTION SINCE
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. WE ARE
NOT THE ONLY COUNTY IN
CALIFORNIA GRAPPLING WITH A
WORSENING OF THE DROUGHT THE
WILDFLOWER FIRES REMEMBER SANTA
BARBARA IN THE MUD SLIDES. THOSE
THINGS WERE COORDINATED AND WE
LOST IT INSTRUCTIONAL DAYS
INCIDENT SANTA BARBARA IN IN
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY AT THE
MONTECITO. EXTREME WEATHER
EVENTS CONTINUE TO MULTIPLY AND
AFFECT MORE OF OUR STATES. THIS
BILL BY ASSEMBLYMAN WOULD WOULD
BE IF IS A STRONG ADVOCATE FOR
OUR LOCAL SCHOOLSDURING RECENT
DISASTERS BEING PREPARED IS WHAT
WE NEED TO DO IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU WELL DONE YOUR NEXT
WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRPERSON O'DONNELL AND
MEMBERS OF THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE I'M SUPERINTENDENT DEB
CUBAN SUPERINTENDENT FOR UKIAH
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
BEAUTIFUL MENDOCINO COUNTY. IN
ADDITION TO THE MANY FIRES WE
HAVE EXPERIENCED OVER THE PAST
FOUR YEARS EIGHT MONTHS AGO WE
HAD AN EXTREMELY CONCERNING FIRE
IN THE HILLS LESS THAN A MILE
DIRECTLY WEST OF OUR HIGH
SCHOOL. SCHOOL IS IN SESSION AND
WE ARE CLOSE TO SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED FIFTY STUDENTS AND STAFF
ON CAMPUS DURING THAT TIME.
THANKFULLY CAL FIGHTER IN OUR
LOCAL RESPONDERS WERE ABLE TO
CONTAIN THE FIRE. DURING A
DEBRIEFING WE DISCUSSED
EVACUATION ROUTES ARE YOU KIND
OF VALLEY- FIRE CHIEF EDUCATED
US ON THE BEST EVACUATION ROUTES
CONSIDERING HOW NGUYEN TYPICALLY
RUNS THROUGH THE AREA BY OUR
HIGH SCHOOL. AND IT WASN'T THE
ROUTE WE HAD IN OUR PLAN- IN
REALITY OUR ROUTE WAS NOT THE
SAFEST ONE CONSIDERING THE WINDS
AT THE TIME. AND COMBINING THE
EXPERTISE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
FIRE ANDEMS WITH OUR
EDUCATIONAL PROFESSIONALS WILL
HELP US DEVELOP THE STRONGEST
CRISIS RESPONSE PLANS. I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN ENOUGH NATURAL
DISASTERS AND DR HARRINGTON
DESCRIBED THEM WE ARE
NEIGHBORING COUNTIES. THAT I
KNOW THERE'S ALWAYS A BIG
LEARNING CURVE WHEN EVERYONE
GETS TO THE TABLE. AT THE MINUTE
COUNTS AND I'M SPENT GETTING ON
THE SAME PAGE TAKES AWAY FROM
PRECIOUS MOMENTS NEEDED TO
ENSURE SAFETY AND SAVE LIVES. WE
NEED TO BE A STEP AHEAD OF THE
NEXT UNKNOWN AND CERTAINLY THERE
WILL BE ONE. DISTRICTS LIKE OURS
IF WE HAD MORE TIME TO
UNDERSTAND IN PLAN IN A DEEPER
MORE HOLISTIC- AGENCY WIDE
COMMUNITY WIDE WAY OUR CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES WOULD ULTIMATELY
COME OUT ON TOP. WHEN WE'RE
CHALLENGED WITH THAT NEXT
NATURAL DISASTER YOU CAN HELP US
PREPARE FOR THE INEVITABLE NEXT
CRISIS I URGE YOU TO PASS AB
TWENTY EIGHT FOURTEEN. AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL YOU'RE DOING
FOR US TO GET OUR SCHOOLS
CONTINUED BACK IN SESSION. IN
PERSON. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WITHOUT ANY OTHER IN WITNESSES
FROM THE PUBLIC THAT WISH TO A
FURTHER SUPPORT SENATE SEAT IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOMS SEEN OFFICE OPPOSITION
THERE ARE GOING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS AMENDED
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS GOOD BILL
OF MOVES RECOMMENDED ACTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY MISTER
BENNETT SECOND AYE MR LEE YOU
MAY CLOSE. THIS RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB TWENTY
EIGHT FOURTEEN. THE MOTION IS
THE PASTOR PREPARATIONS- DONALD
HI DONALD I DALLI. DALLI I'D
SENATE HI SENATE I. CAN CAN I
LEE. LEE AYE. MCCARTY
QUIRK-SILVA. RT I. QUIRK-SILVA
YES SIX VOTE SO IT IS OUT A VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK
YOU MISTER WITH A NEXUS MISTER
GRABEEL SITTING OUT THERE. AND
HE IS THE ONLY MEMBER HERE. SO
THAT MEANS OTHER MEMBERS NEED TO
GET DOWN HERE SO WE CAN HEAR
THEIR BILLS. SO HIS IS IT I HAVE
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN. THAT'S
AB TWO ZERO SEVEN TWO MR GABRIEL
YOU MAY PROCEED ONE READY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS IS MY
FIRST TIME IN THE NEW HEARING
ROOM IT LOOKS NICE SO IT'S GOOD
TO BE WITH YOU I'M IT ACTUALLY
YEAH EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY TWO TWO
ZERO SEVEN TWO. NICE NICE THE
DETAILS OF THE CONVERSATION WE
JUST HAD- THIS IS A BILL THAT
PICKS UP ON A TOPIC THAT I KNOW
YOU AND I HAVE WORKED ON A LOT
WHICH IS THE MENTAL HEALTH OF
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE- AND ALSO BEING
PREPARED FOR DISASTER SITUATIONS
WHETHER THOSE ARE WILD FIRES. OR
MAN MADE DISASTERS SUCH AS GUN
VIOLENCE SITUATIONS AND THE
POINT OF THIS BILLS TO ENCOURAGE
LITTLE LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES
TO COORDINATE AGREEMENTS AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL BETWEEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND CHARTER SCHOOLS TO
DEVELOP A MUTUAL AID SYSTEM THE
KIND THAT THEY HAVE WHEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS RESPONDING TO A
BIG WILD FIRE OR A BIG.
EMERGENCY SITUATION BECAUSEWE
KNOW THAT YOUNG PEOPLE OFTEN
EXPERIENCE TRAUMA AS A RESULT OF
THIS WE KNOW THAT MANY OF OUR
INDIVIDUAL SCHOOLS DO NOT HAVE
SUFFICIENT MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS PERSONALITY NOT
HAVE SUFFICIENT PERSONNEL TO
RESPOND. AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THE TRAUMA OF THOSE EVENTS- CAN
LAST WITH STUDENTS FOR SOME
TIME- AND I THINK A LOT OF US
HAVE LIVE THIS PERSONALLY I
CERTAINLY SITE WHEN THE WEALTHY
FIRE RIPPED THROUGH PART OF MY
COMMUNITY IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. THERE'S SOME REALLY
GOOD STUFF IN THERE IN THE IN
THE ANALYSIS ABOUT HOW FREQUENT
THESE WILDFIRES HAVE BECOME HOW
HOW PROLIFIC THEY BECOME ACROSS
THE STATE AND SO WE WOULD LIKE
TO ENCOURAGE AT THE COUNTY LEVEL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AT CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO WORK WITH EACH OTHER
TO MAKE SURE IN THE EVENT OF A
TRAUMATIC. INCIDENT THEY CAN'T
SHIFT RESOURCES BACK AND FORTH
TO MAKE SURE THAT STUDENTS ARE
GETTING THE SUPPORT THAT THEY
NEED WITHOUT WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AND HAVE WITH
ME TO TESTIFY. DR HARRINGTON THE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT FROM THE
CINEMA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. I'M BEGINNING TO FEEL-LIKE THE POPE. CHILD NATURAL
DISASTER- YOU ARE. YEAH I AM I
HAD A NUMBER OF THEM. YES I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MINSK. GABRIEL'S BILL. I'VE ALSO
BEEN AN ADVOCATE FOR THE UNITED
STATES HOUSE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES ON MUTUAL AID
BILL. AS IT RELATES TO FEMA.
STUDENTS WHO GO THROUGH THE
TRAUMA OF THE NATURAL DISASTER
IT STAYS WITH THEM. YOU HAVE
SMALL COME INTO THE VALLEY
STUDENTS ARE PETRIFIED AGAIN. I
SO I'M HERE TO GIVE YOU AN
ADVOCATE FOR TO YOU. THE REASON
FOR THIS BILL. THE COORDINATES
OF MUTUAL AID TYPE SYSTEM SO
THAT LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES.
CAN QUICKLY DEPLOY A QUALIFIED
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS. AND
OTHER PERSONNEL. IN THE AREAS OF
EXPERIENCE OF NATURAL DISASTER
AND TRAUMA. IN OUR COMMUNITY AS
I STATED EARLIER. WE NEEDED A
ROBUST MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FOR STUDENTS AND BECAME APPARENT
AFTER OUR TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. NORTH BAY WILDFIRE.
WE LOST TO SCHOOLS. FIVE
THOUSAND HOMES. AND THE NEED IS
GROWING FOLLOWING THREE MORE
WILDFIRES IN THROUGH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY. STATE
THE STRESSES BROUGHT ON YEARS.
THE KINDERGARTNERS OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ARE SIXTH GRADERS
TODAY WE ARE STILL DEALING WITH
THAT TRAUMA EVERY TIME SMOKE
COMES IN THE VALLEY. IN RESPONSE
TO THIS NEED AND TO SURVEY THE
DATA SHOWING OF OUR STUDENTS
KNOW COUNTY. CREATED ITS OWN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
DEPARTMENT WITHIN THE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION. BECAUSE IT
WAS SO APPARENT TO ME THAT
CHILDREN NEED OUR SUPPORT.
RESPONDING TO NATURAL DISASTERS
AND OTHER TRAUMATIC EVENTS IS A
YEAR ROUND UNDERTAKING. MY STAFF
WENT OUT TO BE YOU COUNTY WHEN
IT EXPERIENCED THE PARADISE FIRE
BECAUSE WE KNEW THAT THE NEED.
MY COUNTY THE COUNTY WENT OUT TO
MRS CENA COUNTY TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT. BUT THIS IS ONE COUNTY
PROVIDING SUPPORT TO ANOTHER
COUNTY BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IN IT.
BUT WE NEED TO COORDINATE OUR
SERVICES STATEWIDE AND THAT'S
THE PURPOSE THE PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL IS TO COORDINATE THOSE
SERVICES BETWEEN COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION. AND THE LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND SMALL
COUNTIES JOINING TOGETHER TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR MUTUAL AID.
OUR TEAM OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS ALREADY WORK TO
ASSIST SCHOOLS AND THAT WE
DEVELOP RESOURCES. WE HAVE.
BASICALLY ALREADY PROVIDED TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
SOFTWARE SYSTEM WHERE PARENTS
STUDENTS CAN LOG IN AND IDENTIFY
THEIR NEEDS FORCE MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT ALL ALL BASED ON THE
EFFORTS OF OUR OWN EXPERIENCE
BUT THAT SHOULD BE REPLICATED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE GRATEFUL TO
THIS BILL BECAUSE INVEST COUNTY
OFFICES WITH THE FORMER
RESPONSIBILITY OF COORDINATING
HEALTH. SUCH AN APPROACH WILL
HELP ENSURE OUR SCHOOLS WILL BE
PROACTIVE RATHER THAN REACTIVE
IN TERMS OF HOW WE HANDLE THE
COLLECTIVE ACTS OF MULTIPLE
TRAUMAS THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER WITNESSES REPORT SEEING ON
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS DEREK CLASS
WITH THE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS
ASSOCIATION ARE PROCESS COMES
AFTER THIS HEARING BUT WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO SUPPORTING.
THANK YOU- SO NO FURTHER
SUPPORT- ANY MEMBER ANY ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
SAYING NO NO NOBODY IN
OPPOSITION AS BRING IT BACK ANY
COMMENTS FROM ANY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. THE BALLOT. AT I JUST
WOULD LIKE TO OFFER A PERSONAL.
EXPERIENCE TO REINFORCE OF
CERTAINLY THE COMMENTS OF BOTH
THE AUTHOR AND THE
SUPERINTENDENT IT'S TAKING ITS
TIME TO BE HERE TODAY- THAT IS
AT I WAS COACHING- RECENTLY OF A
GROUP OF YOUNG BOYS ABOUT TEN
YEARS OLD. AND THE EXACT SAME
THING HAPPENED SMOKE STARTED
BILLOWING IN. AND WE WENT FROM A
COMPLETE FOCUS ON ATHLETICS. TO
THERE WAS TREMENDOUS KIDS IT
WOULD IT. YOU KNOW IS THERE A
FIRE DO WE HAVE TO GO IT WAS
JUST I WAS AND THIS WAS YEARS
AFTER THE THOMAS FIRE HAD COME
THROUGH SO- YOUR STATEMENT THAT
THIS HAS A REAL IMPACT ON ON
YOUNG PEOPLE FOR A LONG TIME.
THAT IS CERTAINLY WHAT I'VE
EXPERIENCED AND I THINK IT'S A
GREAT BILL THANK YOU A MOVIE
RECOMMENDED ACTION. MENAMBAH
EXECUTIVE. VICE CHAIR DAHLE. SO
SOMEONE WHO IS- IN MY DISTRICT
THE FIRST THE SENATE DISTRICT
WE'VE EXPERIENCED GREENVILLE
LAST YEAR WHICH WAS TERRIBLY
TRAUMATIZING- FOR OUR COMMUNITY
I THINK THE CONCERN FOR ME I
APPRECIATE THE SPELLING I'LL BE
VOTING FOR TODAY IS WE'RE SO
WE'RE SO SHORT MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND OUR RULE
COMMUNITIES I I'M A FORMER
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER SO A MANDATE
COMING DOWN ON TO A SMALL SCHOOL
AND YOU. DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
LICENSED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS TO EVEN TO
COORDINATE BETWEEN THREE SMALL
COUNTIES IS GOING TO BE VERY
DIFFICULT AND LASSEN AND MODOC
AND SIERRA. SO I THINK WE- IN
FUTURE DISCUSSIONS WE REALLY
NEED TO THINK ABOUT PERHAPS
EXEMPTIONS ARE PARTNER SOMEHOW
PARTNERING WITH A LARGER COUNTY
BECAUSE- IT'S ALWAYS SOUNDS
GREAT. BUT WE- WE DON'T HAVE
GRANT WRITERS WE DON'T WE
LITERALLY DON'T HAVE ACCESS SO.
I KNOW YOUR SITUATION WELL AS WE
SINCE STAFF THERE. SO IT IS A
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL LOOKS AT
IS THE DEVELOPING A LINE OF
COMMUNICATION WHO WOULD PLUMAS
CALL ON TO GET SUPPORT. WHERE IS
THAT SUPPORT. WAS A PLASTER
COUNTY OR IS IT- YOU KNOW THAT
WOULD BE THE PROBABLY THE LARGER
COUNTY THE COULD COME UP TO GIVE
YOU SUPPORT. YEAH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
APPRECIATE THE IN THE COMMENTS
AND I THINK THEY'RE WELL TAKEN
I'M HAPPY TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH YOU ABOUT HOW WE MIGHT
CRAFTED WE HAD INTENSELY BAKED.
A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY INTO THIS
BILL BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND THE
NEEDS AND YOU KNOW RURAL
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA MAY BE VERY
DIFFERENT THAN MY COMMUNITY AND
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND SO WE
WANT DISTRICTS TO HAVE THAT
FLEXIBILITY. TO DO THE
COORDINATION THAT'S GOING TO
WORK BEST IN DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE BUT WOULD LOVE
TO GET YOUR FEEDBACK AS WE- MOVE
THIS BILL THROUGH THE PROCESS I
THINK I'D BE HAPPY TO WORK ON
THAT. GREAT THE MANDATE IS THAT
THEY TALK NOT NECESSARILY THAT
THEY HIGH FIVE BODIES IDENTIFIED
THAT THEY CAN CALL RIGHT AWAY.
AND THEY DON'T HAVE LIABILITIES. I'M WITH THAT- WE HAD A MOTION
AND A SECOND- YOU MAY CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FROM ABOUT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- SURGERY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
SEVEN AB TWO ZERO SEVEN TWO THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED YOU
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE.
O'DONNELL I O'DONNELL I DALLI.
DALLI II BENNETT. BENNETT I CAN
. CAN I PLEASE LEAI MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE QUIRK-SILVA YES THE
BILL HAS SIX VOTE SO IT IS OUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
BOTH. IT WITH THAT- WE NEED
AUTHORS HERE WE NEED MR LEVINE-
MISSTATED IS. COOPER WAS ALREADY
DID IT MATTER MISTER CARTER
EDUARDO GARCIA- MISS CARILLO
THIS RUBIO I'M AT THIS MCCARTY-
YOU'RE HERE- MRS THREE OF US.
IT'S RECORDED HERE'S A LITTLE
HAD TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN
IT'S A B.
TWO FIVE SEVEN THREE
SIXTEEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT THIS
BILL IT'S ABOUT- ARE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION SYSTEM AND OUR
TEACHERS WORKING IN CAREER TACK
AND ADULT EDUCATION MAKING SURE
THEY HAVE AMPLE OPPORTUNITIES TO
PURSUE THEIR CAREER GET FAIR
TREATMENT. FIRST I WANT TO START
OFF BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THIS AND
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
. I CALIFORNIA STUDENTS DESERVE
STABLE EXPERIENCE IN HIGH
QUALITY TEACHERS TO HELP THEM
REACH THEIR FULL POTENTIAL.
ESTABLISHING A PATHWAY FOR
QUALIFIED TEACHERS TO ATTAIN
PERMANENT EMPLOYEE STATUS
PROVIDES GREATER STABILITY FOR
BOTH TEACHERS. AND STUDENTS AND
OUR CREATOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY. THIS BILL WILL GIVE
ALL TEACHERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ACHIEVE PERMANENT PERMANENT
EMPLOYEE STATUS PERMIT EMPLOYEES
HAVE A BETTER JOB SECURITY. ARE
ENTITLED TO GREATER DUE PROCESS
RIGHTS AND HAVE PREFERENTIAL RE
HIGHER RATES THAN NON PERMANENT
EMPLOYEES HOWEVER EXISTING LAW.
AS A TWO TIERED SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA WE EXCLUDE SOME
GROUPS OF EDUCATORS FROM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OBTAIN PERMANENT
STATUS. MAINLY FOCUSING ON ADULT
EDUCATION AND CTE TEACHERS TO
AREAS WE NEED. EXTRA ATTENTION
IN CALIFORNIA ALSO TEACHES A
VERY SMALL DISTRICTS AND COUNTY
OFFICES. BLIGHTED CALIFORNIA'S
CRISIS LEVEL TEACHER SHORTAGE
AND COVER NINETEEN WE HAVE AN
ISSUE ENSURING QUALIFIED
TEACHERS ARE ABLE TO RETURN
BASIC PROFESSIONAL RIGHTS THIS
SHOULD BE A NO BRAINER FOR ALL
OF US. BUT THIS IS NOT A FREE
PASS TEACHERS MUST DEAL
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETE. TWO YEAR
PROBATIONARY PERIODS BEFORE THE
EARNED PERMANENT STATUS FURTHER
NOTHING IN THIS BILL PREVENTS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND COUNTY
OFFICES FROM TERMINATING. BERMAN
EMPLOYEES FOR JUST BECAUSE THEY
JUST HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS LIKE OTHER CREDENTIALED
TEACHERS HAVE TO GO. I THIS
ENSURES TEACHERS HAVE PROPER-
RIGHTS AND DUE PROCESS AND WE
HAVE A FAIRNESS FOR ALL
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS IN
CALIFORNIA. WITH ME TO TESTIFY
ARE A LOCAL TEACHER FROM THE L.
GROVE SCHOOL DISTRICT AND A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
. THANK YOU DO YOU WITNESSES.
MAYES A BUTTON THERE. CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK I'M KATIE HARTMAN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION PTA THE CROWD OF
PRODS CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL
ALONG WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WANTED
THANK MISTER MCCARTY AND OUR
OTHER JOINT AUTHORS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I DO KNOW MOST
TEACHERS ARE PROVIDED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OBTAIN PERMANENT
STATUS- AFTER THEY COMPLETE A
PROBATIONARY PERIOD. AND THIS
MEANS THAT THEY HAVE CERTAIN JOB
PROTECTIONS AND DUE PROCESS IF
DISAGREEMENTS ARISE HOWEVER AS
WE HAVE HEARD FROM MANY OF OUR
TEACHERS ACROSS THE STATE THESE
PROTECTIONS ARE NOT PROVIDED TO
ALL EDUCATORS CERTAIN TEACHERS
ARE EXCLUDED INCLUDING THOSE IN
REGIONAL OCT OCCUPATIONAL
CENTERS ADULT EDUCATION PROGRAM
PROGRAMS AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND COUNTY OFFICES WITH LESS
THAN TWO HUNDRED FIFTY STUDENTS.
AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY THREE
WOULD CHANGE THAT TO PROVIDE
THOSE EMPLOYEES WITH THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY AS OTHER TEACHERS AT
OBTAINING PERMANENT STATUS DE TA
BELIEVES ALL TEACHERS SHOULD BE
TREATED AS PROFESSIONALS AND
AFFORDED DUE PROCESS RIGHTS
REGARDLESS OF WHAT SUBJECT THEY
TEACH OR WHAT SCHOOL DISTRICT
THEY TEACHING. THIS BILL DOES
NOT PREVENT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
FROM LAYING OFF STAFF OR
ELIMINATING PROGRAMS DUE TO
CHANGES THE NEEDS AND THERE IS A
PROCESS IN PLACE FOR LAYOFFS AND
MAKING PROGRAM CHANGES THIS BILL
JUST ENSURES THAT TEACHERS ARE
TREATED FAIRLY AND
PROFESSIONALLY IN THAT PROCESS.
MANY OF OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
EXPERIENCING UNPRECEDENTED
TEACHER AND STOCKINGS SHORTAGES
AS YOU ALL KNOW AND THIS BILL
WILL PROVIDE MORE STABILITY FOR
OUR TEACHER WORKFORCE AND WE
KNOW THAT IT'S BETTER FOR
STUDENTS SO. I URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. HI MY NAME'S DAVE
SWINDLE I AM AN ADULT ED TEACHER
WITH ELK GROVE UNIFIED SCHOOL
pTEACHER. I'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE
OF FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS OF
WORKING WITH ADULTS. AT R.
GERBER OFFICE AS WELL AS WITH-
STUDENTS IN OUR JAILS AT
SACRAMENTO COUNTY JAIL AND RIO
CONSUME THAT'S CORRECTION CENTER
. SO THIS UP. TODAY WANT TO TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT MY ROLE AS A
TEACHER AND REALLY HOW THIS BILL
WOULD AFFECT US- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT HAPPENED AS I HAVE
COME FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR. I
WORKED IN THE CLEANING INDUSTRY
FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS. SO I
TEACH THE CUSTODIAL TRADES AND
IN DOING SO- IT'S ALL. BEEN A
VERY LUCRATIVE THING WHERE I'VE
BEEN ABLE TO HELP A LOT OF
STUDENTS BE ABLE TO ATTAIN JOBS
WHEN THEY COME OUT OF JAIL. IT'S
LOWER DOT SOME OF THE RECIDIVISM
ISSUES THAT WE SEE WITH
STUDENTS. BUT ALSO BEING ABLE TO
SEE THEM COULD FOLLOW A CAREER
PATHWAY. SO THAT'S PROVIDER BE A
LOT OF JOY. AT THE REALITY IS
THOUGH I LEFT A VERY LUCRATIVE
POSITION TO BE ABLE TO BECOME A
TEACHER. I DID THAT BECAUSE I
HAD A PASSION FOR TEACHING AND
FOR HELPING PEOPLE. ONE OF THE
THINGS I DIDN'T KNOW WHEN I TOOK
ON THIS ROLE IS THAT MY POSITION
AS A TEACHER WAS A TEMPORARY
ONE. WHERE EVERY YEAR I WOULD BE
LAID OFF FROM MY POSITION. AND
EVERY YEAR I WOULD HAVE TO BE
REHIRED. BUT THAT DIDN'T KNOW
THAT THAT WAS GOING TO BE THE
CASE SO FOR ME TO BE ABLE TO SEE
SOMETHING THAT WOULD CHANGE
THAT. AND ALLOW ME TO KNOW THAT
I HAVE. AN ABILITY TO GROW IN MY
CAREER AND CONTINUE TO HELP
INDIVIDUALS AND STUDENTS. REALLY
IS SOMETHING THAT IS IMPORTANT
TO ME AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO MY
FELLOW TEACHERS AND ADULT
EDUCATION. SO THIS IS ASUB
MIGHT. ASK YOU GUYS TO GIVE
CONSIDERATION TO. AND I ALSO
THINK ABOUT OUR STUDENTS THE
BENEFITS THAT WE CAN BRING TO
OUR STUDENTS AND HOW IT'S GOING
TO AFFECT- ADULTS THROUGHOUT THE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SO. I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHERS IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON NAVNEET PER YEAR
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. FIFTY MARK ON
BEHALF OF CFT A UNION EDUCATORS
AND CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS WE
ORDER SUPPORT AS A PROUD BECAUSE
BONSER. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
PATTERSON ON THE AUTOMOTIVE
TEACHER AT SOUTH TAHOE HIGH
SCHOOL ALSO SERVE ON THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
REPRESENTING TEACHERS ON THE
NORTH STATE- THE ONES THAT DON'T
HAVE PERMANENT STATUS BECAUSE
ROOTS WHILE COUNTY OFFICES AND
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ALEXANDER KHANDAN AND YELLED
INSTRUCTIONAL COACH AND TEACHER
AND OAK GROVE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT I'VE ALSO WITH CTA. AND
HAVE WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE
ADULT EDUCATION TEACHERS AS A
LEADER AT MY LOCAL THINK UNITED
I AM SPEAKING IN SUPPORT. ANY
OTHERS IN SUPPORT SEEM TO OTHERS
IN SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL YOU CAN COME FORWARD.
SOMEONE MIGHT HAVE TO. THERE'S
TWO THERE'S TWO FOLKS COME UP TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT ALL THANK
YOU.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY. A
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR VICE
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS RICH TO BARNEY TAME A
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS SCHOOLS
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION S.
STA AS OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY THREE BECAUSE OF ITS
EFFECT IT WOULD BE HAVE ON THE
STATE SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION. AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY THREE WOULD
REDUCE SMALL DISTRICTS AND
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION'S
ABILITY TO ADDRESS CHANGING
NEEDS OF THEIR STUDENTS
POPULATION FOR ELEAZAR WITHIN
ABA OF LESS THAN TWO FIFTY EVEN
SLIGHT FLUCTUATIONS IN STUDENT
ENROLLMENT CHANGES STAFFING
NEEDS. IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
SMALL ONLY AS RETAIN THE ABILITY
TO BE RESPONSIVE TO CHANGES THE
STUDENT ENROLLMENT AS OUR
BUDGETS DO NOT ALLOW US TO KEEP
THE WORK FORCE BEYOND WHAT IS
NEEDED TO SERVE OUR STUDENTS AND
SCHOOL COMMUNITY CURRENT LAW
ALLOWS A LEASE WITH THE SMALL
STUDENT ENROLLMENT TO BE ADEPT
AT STE MEETING STAFFING
CHALLENGES AND HEARD. OF BEING
SMALL THERE IS PRECEDENT
THROUGHOUT ADD CODE TO TREAT
SMALLER DISTRICTS DIFFERENTLY
FOR EXAMPLE SMALL DISTRICTS ARE
EXEMPT FROM BUDGET RESERVE CAP
AND NECESSARY SMALLSCHOOLS
RECEIVE ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDING
TO SUPPORT THEIR OPERATIONS SSPA
ALSO HAS REAL CONCERN WITH THE
BILL'S LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
PROBATIONER TEACHERS CREDIT FOR
A FULL YEAR SERVED SO LONG AS A
PROBATIONARY EMPLOYEE SERVES
JUST 75% OF THE NUMBER OF DAYS
REQUIRED OF THE ASSIGNMENT
REGARDLESS OF THE ASSIGNMENT
DURATION. ASSIGNMENTS OFTEN
INCLUDE PART TIME EMPLOYMENT THE
SPANS ONLY A FEW MONTHS AND
SOMETIMES. SO THIRTY DAY CONTRA
SIXTY DAY CONTRACT WOULD- SEND
THAT PERSON ON THEIR WAY TO
PERMANENCY. THESE ASIGNMENT
COURAGE DO NOT PROVIDE THE TIME
NEEDED USTO ASSESS PROBATIONARY
TEACHERS AND ENSURE THAT THEY
HAVE SKILLS ALL OF OUR KIDS
DESERVE IN THEIR EDUCATORS.
NEARLY HALF OF OUR COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION AND 20% OF
DISTRICTS HAVE AN ETA OF TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY OR LESS. THESE
REPRESENT A DISTINCT TYPE OF L.
EA IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT
WE VALUE OUR TEACHERS
TREMENDOUSLY. BUT WE CANNOT HIDE
FROM THE REALITIES OF WORKING IN
OUR STATE'S SMALLEST OF SMALLS
WERE NEEDS CHANGE RAPIDLY AND
OFTEN WITHOUT NOTICE NOTICE FOR
THESE REASONS SST A REQUEST THAT
YOU VOTE NO ON THIS BILL. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN OF DONALD
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JULIE DUNCAN
I'M REPRESENTING K. ROB IN THE
C. T. E. J. P. A. COALITION
COMPRISED OF R. C. P. R. P.
PROGRAM THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
UNFORTUNATELY I'M HERE TODAY TO
RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY THREE
AND THE SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS IT
WILL HAVE AN R. O. P. PROGRAMS.
I'M NOT HERE TO OPPOSE TEACHERS
HAVING DUE PROCESS IN THE LAYOUT
PROCESS. HOWEVER THIS BILL WILL
CREATE HUGE HURDLES- PLACE AN
IMPOSSIBLE BURDEN ON EMPLOYERS
IF YOU'RE FORCED TO IMPLEMENT
LAYOFFS. THAT RELIANCE SENIORITY
. AS THE PRIMARY CONSIDERATION
RATHER THAN SUCCESSFUL
INNOVATIVE AND INDUSTRY RELEVANT
PATHWAYS WE TEACH. CURRENT
STATURE ALLOWS OUR PEACE TO BE
FLEXIBLE SO WE CAN ADAPT OUR CTE
PATHWAYS ALWAYS TO SAY CURRENT
AND RELEVANT. TO THE LOCAL AND
STATE ECONOMIES. INDUSTRY
CHANGES AND AFFECTS WHAT COURSES
WE OFFER OR WE DON'T OFFER BASED
ON LOCAL WORKFORCE NEEDS. FOR
THIS REASON RP STUDENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO CLASSES LIKE VIDEO
GAME ART DESIGN CYBERSECURITY
SPORTS MEDICINE. ROP COURSES AND
PROGRAMS TO MAXIMIZE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR STUDENTS TO
OBTAIN EMPLOYMENT. OR RESULT IN
FURTHER EDUCATION IN THE FIELD
OF STUDY SO THEY HAVE CAREERS BY
CHOICE AND NOT BY CHANCE.
IMPLEMENTING SEARED SENIORITY
BASED LAYOFFS WOULD FORCE US TO
RETAIN TEACHERS AND PROGRAMS
THAT MAY NOT HAVE LABOR MARKET
DEMAND. OR FOR WHICH THEY DON'T
HAVE THE PROPER EXPERTISE IN
TRAINING BECAUSE THE WAY C. G.
CREDENTIALS ARE STRUCTURED. FOR
EXAMPLE A TEACHER IN DENTISTRY
HAS THE SAME EXACT SEJUK HE
CREDENTIAL HEALTH SCIENCE. AS A
TEACHER IN SPORTS MEDICINE. A
NETWORK TECHNICIAN HAS EXACT
SAME ICT CREDENTIAL AS A
COMPUTER PROGRAMMER. BUT IF I
NEED TO IMPLEMENT A LAYOFF THAT
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE ME TO
LAY OFF BASED ON SENIORITY AND
NOT THE COURSE THAT HAS GREATER
INDUSTRY DEMAND BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE SAME EXACT
CREDENTIAL. ARE- HE'S ALSO DO
NOT HAVE STABLE FUNDING.
DEDICATED FUNDING WITH THE
ELIMINATION OF KARAKUL FUNNY ARE
UP HE'S REALLY ON RELY ON YOUR
TO YOUR ON COMPETITIVE GRANTS
SUCH AS THE C. T. AND CENTER
GRANT THANK YOU O'DONNELL. AND
K. TWELVE STRONG WORKFORCE
GRANTS BOTH. SUPPLEMENT ARE
FUNDING BUT DO NOT COVER A
FRACTION OF OUR COST. AND AGAIN
OUR FUNDING IS COMPETITIVE NOT
GUARANTEED. ARE YOU MANY FUNDS
TO OPERATE OR DEPENDENT YOUR
YOUR UPON MEMBER DISTRICTS AND
COUNTIES LOCAL DECISIONS. THE
CLASSES WE OFFER OUR A LACK. IN
OUR LOCAL DECISIONS ON STUDENT A
MAN. LABOR WORK FOR SEASON
PRIORITIES OF THE DISTRICTS NOW
MORE THAN EVER ARE ABUSING TO
RETAIN THE CURRENT LAW. THAT
GIVES US THIS FLEXIBILITY FOR
PROGRAMS. FOR THESE REASONS
PLEASE RECONSIDER THE IMPACT AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY FIVE WOULD
HAVE AN R. O. P. PROGRAMS. THE
PATHWAYS WE OFFER TO STUDENTS
SHOULD BE DICTATED BY THE LABOR
MARKET NEEDS. NOT TO YOUR
SENIORITY OF TEACHERS YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION. MAY COME
FORWARD. GOOD AFTERNOON DEREK
LENNIX ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON
DOROTHY JOHNSON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION AND
THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION RESPECTFULLY POST.
ELIZABETH ASK OF ALL OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SEE YOU
KNOW FURTHER OPPOSITION WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY COMMENTS OR MANY OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MISTER
BENNETT A- IT TO THE AUTHOR I
CASTERLY SUPPORT YOUR CONCEPT IT
WITH REGARDS TO THE SMALL
SCHOOLS AND- GETTING THEM ON THE
SAME TENURE TRACK- I DO THINK
SOME OF THE ISSUES RAISED BY THE
R. O. P- PEOPLE ARE WILL THAT I
HOPE AS IS I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL THAT I HOPE YOU'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM AND
SEE IF YOU CAN WORK THOSE THOSE-
THOSE ISSUES OUTSIDE OF THE RP
PROGRAMS ARE. MORE COMPLICATED
AND TO BE MORE NIMBLE- AS WE
MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU GREAT
THANK YOU I JUST A COMMENT ON
THAT TOPIC MISTER BENNETT. AS I
UNDERSTAND IT ACTUALLY LAW
TODAY. DOESN'T NECESSARILY. THE
LAST IN FIRST OUT. IT'S A
MISNOMER AND THAT'S- PROMULGATED
BY GROUPS WHO WANT TO GET
TEACHERS FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IT
SAYS IF I'M CORRECT I THINK I AM
IS LAST IN FIRST OUT AND LAST.
THAT LOCAL SCHOOL BOARD ADOPTS A
DIFFERENT POLICY. SO TO BE ON
THE SCHOOL BOARD TO ADOPT A
DIFFERENT POLICY I DO AND I DO
UNDERSTAND YOUR CONCERN. MR
THANK YOU SO OCT BEFORE I WAS
ELECTED TO THE ASSEMBLY I SAT ON
A VERY SMALL SCHOOL BOARD- I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED BECAUSE I THINK
WITH IT THIS IS ACTUALLY GONNA
DO IS WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO LAY A
TEACHER OFF WITHIN THE FIRST
YEAR BECAUSE YOU DON'T KNOW I
HAVE SCHOOLS ROBIN DISTRICT
THERE WERE FIRES OR SCOLDED WE
HAD CHILDREN MOVING 30% OF KIDS
MOVE FROM ONE SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
ANOTHER SO YOU HAD TO UP YOUR
TEACHERS AT THAT SCHOOL DISTRICT
THAT WAS OPENED IN PERSON. THEN
THERE THEN THE NEXT YEAR YOU'RE
BUDGET LOOKS DIFFERENTLY BECAUSE
THOSE CHILDREN HAVE GONE BACK TO
ANOTHER SCHOOL I THINK THIS IS-
TIME TO POORLY BECAUSE OUR
SCHOOLS ARE REELING RIGHT NOW
AND ARE STILL HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ON HOW THEY'RE GOING
TO BE FUNDED IN THE YEARS TO
COME I RESPECT TEACHERS VERY
MUCH AND I WOULD LOVE AS A
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER I WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE BEEN ABLE TO SAY
PERMANENT STATUS FOR ALL OF THEM
THAT CAME THROUGH BECAUSE I
VALUE THE WORK THAT YOU DO. BUT-
BUDGETS ARE WHAT THEY ARE AND
I'M I AM VERY CONCERNED THIS IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO HAVE. THE
OPPOSITE. EFFECT FOR TEACHERS
ARE GOING TO FEEL EVEN MORE
LESS- SECURE IN THEIR JOBS
BECAUSE OUR OUR SMALL SCHOOLS
WHICH THIS LITERALLY TARGETS MY
ENTIRE DISTRICT. SO I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSED TODAY. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER COMMENTS FROM
ANY OF THE OTHER COMMITTEES MR
LEE. THANKS TO SHARE. I THANK
THE AUTHOR BRING THIS BILL BACK
AGAIN FOR THIS COMMITTEE I
CERTAINLY AS WE'RE GRAPPLING
WITH TEACHER RETENTION
RECRUITMENT RIGHT NOW ACROSS THE
STATE I DO HOPE THAT THIS
MEASURE GIVES ONE MORE PIECE OF
MIND TO ARE. A DIFFERENT
TEACHERS DIFFERENT SITUATIONS
CERTAINLY I DON'T THINK IT'S
FAIR FOR THEM TO AS YOU SAID
YOUR STORY THAT YOU HAVE TO GET
HIRED YOUR FEW WITHOUT THAT KIND
OF HIS IDEA AS WE ALREADY HAVE.
A HARD ENOUGH TIME ATTRACT NEW
TALENT OF COURSE THEY DO SHARE
SOME OF THE COMMENTS FROM
WILLIAM BENNETT ABOUT HOW WE CAN
ADAPT TO MAKE SURE CITY SCHOOLS
CAN STAY NIMBLE I THINK THERE
MUST BE SOME BELTING NIP YOU
KNOW RESPONDING TO THE- CLASSES
THE TRADES I NEED TO BE TAUGHT
WITHOUT. SACRIFICING THE PEOPLE
THAT TEACH IT IN A WAY I THINK
THAT ON BALANCE THERE AND I DO
HOPE YOU'LL BE ABLE TO WORK WITH
R. J- OUR CITY SCHOOLS IDEA CITY
SCHOOL IN MY DISTRICT AS WELL
THAT. I'D CERTAINLY IS VERY
VALUABLE BUT WE WANT TO
HOPEFULLY TREAT THOSE WORKERS
AND EDUCATES RESPECTABLE SO HAVE
YOU SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY- AND
TECHNICAL. IT KNOW WHAT MISTER
MARK. CAN AS CHAIR OF SUB. TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. THIS MAKE
SURE THAT WE ADEQUATELY. FUND
OUR SCHOOLS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- AND I KNOW HE'S
GOING TO DO THAT. SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ANY OF THE CALAMITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN SUGGESTED. MISTER
BENNETT. I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
ONE THING AS- I DO I THINK THE
IDEA. I JUST. MY VIEW FOR THE
RECORD IDEA THE IDEA THAT WE
WOULD HAVE TO LAY TEACHERS OFTEN
THEIR FIRST YEAR. MY PERCEPTION
AFTER BEING AN ADMINISTRATOR FOR
QUITE SOME TIME IT. IS THAT
THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU HAVE TO IT'S
THE SECOND YEAR THAT YOU HAVE TO
MAKE THE HARD DECISION AS AN
ADMINISTRATOR- MOVING FORWARD
NOT. NOT THE FIRST YEAR. OF THE
FIRST YEAR IT'S VERY CLEAR IS A
SECOND YEAR BY MARCH WHEN YOU
HAVE TO SEND OUT THAT EMPLOYMENT
LETTER. THAT STARTS THEM FOR THE
THIRD YEAR SO. YOU DO HAVE TIME
AND- MY EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN
ADMINISTRATORS ARE EITHER GOING
TO GET IT IN GEAR AND GET OUT
AND DO THE EVALUATIONS AND ALL
THAT ARE. OR THEY AREN'T AND- SO
THAT'S THAT'S PART OF. WHY I
THINK IT'S- IT'S JUSTIFIED. IN
IN TERMS OF DOING THIS **** SO.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
THAT- THAT WAS CLARIFIED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU- MISTER
MCCARTY MAY CLOSE YEAH I THINK
YOU KNOW JUST ADDRESS SOME OF
THE ISSUES AS WELL SO I'LL TALK
TO. THE BILL ON THE MERITS AND
SECOND BUT JUST THE BIG PICTURE.
THE FISCAL ISSUE NOT A FEW OF
YOU ARE ON OUR SUBCOMMITTEE. WE
DON'T HAVE A MONEY PROBLEM HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. IN A PEOPLE
PROBLEM. WE CAN GET PEOPLE TO
FILL THE JOBS THAT THAT'S THE
ISSUE WE SPENT FOUR HOURS
YESTERDAY. TALKING ABOUT HOW WE
SPENT LAST YEAR. ONE BILLION
DOLLARS. TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN.
TEACHERS WERE DOING BRING PEOPLE
INSTRUMENT WHEN TO MAKE IT
EASIER. TO GET THIS PERFECT
PROFESSION WHY WOULD YOU WANT TO
GO INTO PROFESSIONAL IT'S-
UNSTABLE YET TO JUMP AROUND YOU
HAVE TO GO TO COLLEGE FOR
ADDITIONAL YEAR. IT AN
ADDITIONAL- THAT DEBT LOAD. TO
GET A JOB THAT PAYS LESS THAN
YOUR FRIENDS GET WITH A FOUR
YEAR DEGREE SO IT'S ALREADY
SUPER HOW. COMPLICATED GET
PEOPLE TAKE A JOB IN THE FIRST
PLACE. AND THEN YOU KNOW
RESPECTFULLY TO OUR VICE CHAIR.
FORMER SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER-
WE'VE SINCE. SINCE WE GOT
ACTUALLY SINCE THE OTHER DOLLAR
GOT HERE YOU'RE THE BETTER DOLLY
OF COURSE. IS THE OTHER DOLLY
GOT HERE IN TWENTY TWELVE. WE'VE
DOUBLED SCHOOL FUNDING. DOUBLED
LIKE THE PER PUPIL FUNDING IS
DOUBLED WHEN WE WERE A DECADE
AGO RED RECORD LEVELS OF SCHOOL
FUNDING SO WE DO. NOT HAVE ANY
PROBLEM EIGHTY EIGHT GOING OUT
IN THE FUTURE. VERY VERY EVEN
MORE SO ROSY WITH THIS WHOLE
BEGAN SITUACIÓN THE ONE THING
THAT WE KNOW WILL WIN IN THE
SITUATION SCHOOLS ARE MORE AND
MORE MONIES TO GOING TO PROP THE
IN OUR SCHOOLS WE JUST NEED TO
GET PEOPLE. TO GO AND WORK IN
THIS PROFESSION AND REALLY IT'S
NOT THAT COMPLICATED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS YOUR SCHOOL DISTRICT
MY SCHOOL DISTRICT WE DO THIS
ANYWAY. 94% OF TEACHERS ANYWAY
WE JUST HAVE THE SECOND TIER.
RULES FOR PEOPLE THAT WORK IN
THIS CATEGORY OF WORKING IN OUR
SCHOOLS THIS IS BRINGS ABOUT A
FAIRNESS AND I THINK THAT WE'VE
WORKED TO FIND- A SOLUTION HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IN YOUR
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
ARAMBULA. GREAT THANK YOU I JUST
JUST A COMMENT MR MCCARTY. I
THINK WE DO HAVE A MONEY PROBLEM
AND THAT IS WHERE THE MONEY
GOES. THE SEVILLA PROPOSED
BUDGET FOR THIS YEAR IT'S
DRIVING MONEY AWAY IN THE
CLASSROOM AND I JUST ROB NINETY
EIGHT MONEY AWAY FROM THE
CLASSROOM AND I JUST THINK
THAT'S TRAGIC I KNOW THE BUDGET
IS AN EXERCISE. YOU'RE PART OF
IT- BUT PEOPLE SHOULD TAKE NOTE
THAT THE A LOT OF MONEY IN THE
BUDGET THIS YEAR IS NOT GOING
INTO THE CLASSROOM WILL NOT BE
SPENT ON TEACHING. RIGHT AND
THAT TO ME IS A TRAGEDY WE NEED
TO FUND THE BASE. SO WE GET
TEACHERS RIGHT AND GET KIDS
EDUCATE WORK WITH ON THAT YES
THANK YOU FOR THAT I DO WE DO
HAVE A MOTION. THIS LEE WHEN YOU
MOVE. AS A MR LEE AND MR BY. YOU
PLEASE CALDERON. FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY
THREE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL HI O'DONNELL I DALY NO
VALLEY KNOW BENNETT BENNETT I
CHEN. CHEN NO LEAVE LEAI MCCARTY
. I QUIRK-SILVA. YEAH FOUR THE
BILL HAS FOUR VOTES IT IS OUT.
IT DID PASS AND- IT BUT IT IS ON
CALL I WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT AYE MR
LEVINE. YOU MAY COME FORWARD AND
PROCEED WHEN READY MR LEVINE.
THANKYOU VERY MUCH AND GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB
EIGHTEEN TEN WOULD ESTABLISH THE
SEIZURE SAFE SCHOOLS ACT TO
ALLOW SCHOOLS TO DESIGNATE ONE
OR MORE VOLUNTEERS TO RECEIVE
INITIAL AND ANNUAL REFRESHER
TRAINING FOR THE EMERGENCY USE
OF ANTI SEIZURE MEDICATION. FOR
A PEOPLE DIAGNOSED WITH SEIZURES
SEIZURE DISORDER OR EPILEPSY IF
THE PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING FROM A
SEIZURE THE VOLUNTEER WOULD BE
TRAINED IN RECOGNIZING THE SIGNS
AND SYMPTOMS OF SEIZURES IN THE
APPROPRIATE STEPS TO TAKE TO
RESPOND TO THOSE SYMPTOMS THE
VOLUNTEER WOULD ALSO BE PROVIDED
WITH THE STUDENT'S
INDIVIDUALIZED SEIZURE ACTION
PLAN. WHICH WOULD INCLUDE
INFORMATION FROM THE STUDENTS
DOCTOR AND PARENTS. THERE ARE
NEARLY SIXTY THOUSAND CHILDREN
LIVING WITH EPILEPSY IN
CALIFORNIA AND I AM THE FATHER
OF ONE SEIZURES ARE
UNPREDICTABLE AND CAN OCCUR
ANYTIME INCLUDING DURING THE
HOURS A CHILD IS AT SCHOOL.
SCHOOL NURSES ARE TRAINED TO
ADMINISTER MEDICATION BUT MAY
NOT BE ON SITE OR AVAILABLE TO
ADMINISTER ANTI SEIZURE
MEDICATION WHEN ONE OCCURS
CALIFORNIA HAS ENACTED SIMILAR
LAWS FOR THE USE OF BENEFITING.
FOR ALLERGIC REACTIONS ANILOX
OWN FOR OPIOID OVERDOSES IN
ADDITION TWELVE STATES ALREADY
HAVE IMPLEMENTED VERSIONS OF THE
SEIZURE SAFE SCHOOLS ACT AB
EIGHTEEN TEN WOULD PROVIDE
SCHOOL SITES WITH THE
INFORMATION AND TRAINING
NECESSARY TO AID CHILDREN LIKE
MY SON. WHO HAVE SEIZURES WHILE
ON CAMPUS AND CREATE A SAFER
ENVIRONMENT FOR THESE CHILDREN
TO SUCCEED AND STAY IN SCHOOL.
THANK YOU MISTER LIVING TO YOUR
WITNESSES. A GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME'S ROCK HOLLOW WELL IN THE
DIRECTOR OF THE EPILEPSY
FOUNDATION LOS ANGELES THANK YOU
ALL SO MUCH FOR HAVING US HERE
TODAY I OUR ORGANIZATION WORKS
CLOSELY WITH THE APPLE OF THE
FOUNDATION THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA- TO ENSURE THE RIGHTS
OF NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS WITH
EPILEPSY. AND UP WHICH WAS
NEARLY. AT BEST THE REALITY IS
THAT WE'RE NOT THERE YEAH THAT'S
ODD THE FACT IS THAT A PERSON
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE A LICENSED
MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL TO ASSIST A
STUDENT DURING A SEIZURE I WE'RE
ACTUALLY CURRENTLY IN THE
SCHOOLS ARE PROVIDING TRAINING
OBSCURE RECOGNITION A RESPONSE
INCLUDING THE ADMINISTRATION OF.
EMERGENCY SEIZURE RESCUE
MEDICATION WE'RE SO GRATEFUL FOR
THE MANY SCHOOL EMPLOYEES WHO DO
STEP UP ON THEIR OWN A CAR OR A
CORD TO LEARN SO THEY CAN BE IN
POSITION TO HELP RATHER THAN
FEEL HELP LESS- HOWEVER WE OWE
IT TO OUR KIDS- TO IMPROVE UPON
THE CURRENT LANDSCAPE BY
OFFERING BETTER SUPPORT AND
GUIDANCE AND CLARIFICATION. AB
EIGHTEEN TEN DOES JUST THAT
PURPOSE BY PROVIDING A UNIFORM
STANDARD OF TRAINING FOR
VOLUNTEERS I DR- CHUY'S HE'S A
P. AFTER A COUPLE OF TALA JUST-
FROM SACRAMENTO SUTTER US AT OUR
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL WANTED TO BE
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY BUT HE
ACTUALLY HAS- CLINIC TODAY AND
YOU REALLY WANT ME TO EMPHASIZE
THAT TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE WHEN
RESPONDING TO A SEIZURE. AND IT
CAN PREVENT INJURY AND OTHER
WORSE OUTCOMES ARE SO BOTTOM
LINE A LITTLE BIT OF TRAINING
CAN GO A LONG WAY TOWARDS
PROTECTING A CHILD WITH EPILEPSY
I JUST BILL ALSO SAFEGUARDS
PHYSICIAN DIRECTED CARE BY
SUPPORTING THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
SEIZURE ACTION PLAN. AND LASTLY
THIS BILL FURTHER GUARANTEES
LEGAL PROTECTIONS FOR EMPLOYEES
WHO VOLUNTEER TO SUPPORT THAT
STUDENT SO WE'RE CONFIDENCE WITH
THE ULTIMATE PASSAGE BILL AYE
YOU'LL BE IMPROVING THE QUALITY
OF LIFE AND REDUCING THE RISK OF
INJURY AND DEATH FOR OUR
STUDENTS THAT LAPSE E. OB
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR BY
BOAT. THANK YOU THANK YOU TO THE
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU I THANK
YOU CHAIRED. WHEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE AND ALL THE
MEMBERS THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO
YOU TODAY. MY NAME IS DAVID
PARKER AND I'M TO TELL YOU ABOUT
MY SEVEN YEAR OLD DAUGHTER
VIVIAN. FIFTEEN WAS PLAYING
BARBIES HANG OUT WITH A LITTLE
SISTER DAPHNE AND SEEING OUR
FRIENDS AT SCHOOL. HE'S ALSO
BEEN HAVING SEIZURES SINCE HE
WAS FIVE MONTHS OLD. VIVIAN
STARTED KINDERGARTEN PERSON LAST
APRIL A CHILD'S FIRST DAY OF
SCHOOL IS EMOTIONAL STRESSFUL
FOR ANY PARENT. FOR MY WIFE
HILLARY IN MAY IT WAS ALSO
TERRIFYING. IT'S NOT EASY
LEAVING A SIX YEAR OLD EPILEPSY
SOMEWHERE NEW WE BASICALLY NEVER
DONE IT. WE WAITED OUTSIDE THE
SCHOOL THAT ENTIRE FIRST DAY
JUST IN CASE. WHEN IT WENT OFF
WITHOUT A HITCH IN VIVIAN CAME
OUT BEAMING AND PROUD WE WERE
ECSTATIC. THE NEXT DAY I WAITED
OUTSIDE THE SCHOOL AGAIN WE
WEREN'T READY TO BE FAR AWAY.
DROP OF A GONE SMOOTHLY AND
VIVIAN WAS EXCITED TO BE BACK AT
SCHOOL. I WAS HAVING COFFEE
ACROSS THE STREET IN MY PHONE
RANG. IT WAS THE SCHOOL. BEFORE
EVEN ANSWERED MY HEART JUMPED
INTO MY THROAT I KNEW WHAT THE
CALL WAS ABOUT LEVINE WAS HAVING
A SEIZURE. THIS WAS THE MOMENT
WE FEARED. BY THE TIME I MADE IT
BACK TO THE SCHOOL I WAS
SWEATING AND BREATHLESS.
WHATEVER ELSE WAS CALM. THE
TEACHERS KIDS. EVEN VIVIAN WHO
SAID YOU SEE YOUR IT ENDED I WAS
NOW RESTING SAFELY IN OUR SIDE.
BLANKET CAREFULLY FOLDED
UNDERNEATH HER HEAD. I RAN OVER
TO CYNTHIA THE CLASSROOM AIDE
WHO TAKING CARE OF IT AND- HE
TOLD ME EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED AS
SHE RESPONDED ALONG CEDAR
LASTED. I THANK HER AND ASK HER
A LITTLE INCREDULOUS HOW DID YOU
STAY SO CALM. AND SHE SAID. IT
WAS ALL THE TRAINING WE KNEW
WHAT TO DO. A WEEK BEFORE A
HANDFUL OF EMPLOYEES AT VIVIAN
SCHOOL HAD VOLUNTEERED TO ATTEND
A BRIEF TRAINING. WITH A SCHOOL
NURSE ON RECOGNIZING AND
RESPONDING TO SEIZURES. THEY
LEARN ABOUT WHAT'S YOUR LOOK
LIKE. THEY LEARNED THAT IF YOU
HAD A SEIZURE TO TURN AROUND OUR
SITE AND PROTECTOR HAD. LEARNED
WHEN IT WOULD BE TIME TO GIVE
YOU HER MERCY MEDICATION. AND
WE'RE THAT MEDICATION WOULD BE
AND HOW TO USE IT. EVER IN THAT
ROOM WAS PREPARED FOR A SEIZURE.
THAT'S WHY THEY WERE ABLE TO
STAY SO CALM. ND ALSO KEEP
VIVIAN'S CLASSMATES COM.
AVOIDING WHAT COULD HAVE BEEN A
TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCE FOR
EVERYONE THERE. AND THE NEXT
DAY. OR THIRD DAY OF
KINDERGARTEN. THE TRUTH IS THAT
PROBABLY WILL BE THE LAST SEIZE
EVERYTHING HAS A SCHOOL BUT IT
WAS THE LAST TIME MY WIFE RISE
BEEN CAN TIRED A SITTING
OUTSIDE. JUST IN CASE. I HOPE
YOU'LL SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT
BILL AND HELP KEEP KIDS LIKE
VIVIAN SAY THAT'S COOL. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR STORY. THANK YOU.
ARE WITH THAT OTHERS IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
MEMBERS I'M CHARLES KILBOURNE
HAVE A BOARD MEMBER OF THE
EPILEPSY FOUNDATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND I'M A SEIZURE
FIRST AID TRAINER IN ADULTS WITH
EPILEPSY AND FULL SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU A SEEN OTHERS IN
SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. SEEING NO OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL IS BRING IT BACK THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
MOVED BY- VICE CHAIR DOLLY.
SECOND BY MISTER LEE. ARE YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS ISSUE
FOR A VERY LONG TIME I'M
GRATEFUL FOR- THE SUSTAINED
ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE WHICH IS
A GOOD. PERSONALLY
EXTRAORDINARILY MEANINGFUL BUT I
KNOW THAT ON BEHALF OF FAMILIES
LIKE THE PARKERS- CAN MAKE
PEOPLE FEEL A LOT MORE
COMFORTABLE AND CHILDREN A LOT
SAFER AT SCHOOL. ND I AM
GRATEFUL FOR THE THIS DISCOURSE
THAT WE HAD TODAY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
UP AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WITNESSES. OF THESE CALDERON.
FILE ITEM THREE AB EIGHTEEN TEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
BUT DONALD HI. DONALD I DALLI.
DALLI II BENNETT HI. SENATE AYE
CHAN. CHAN I'D LI. LI I MCCARTY
. MCCARTY II QUIRK-SILVA. THE
HAS SIX VOTE IS IT IS OUT OF
COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR SURE THANK YOU I WOULD THAT
WILL GO TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX
MISS DAVIES IT'S EIGHTY TWO ZERO
TWO EIGHT. FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. MEMBERS
TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB TWO
ZERO TWO EIGHT. I FIRST WANT TO
THANK COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING
WITH MY STAFF ON THIS MEASURE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW EDUCATIONAL
CODE. FIVE ONE EIGHT SIX ZERO
STATES THAT THE GOVERNING BOARD
OF ANY SCHOOL DISTRICT HAVING
JURISDICTION. OVER ANY
ELEMENTARY INTERMEDIATE OR
JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL MAY PROVIDE
TIME AND FACILITIES TO ANY LOCALLAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. HAVING
JURISDICTION OVER THE SCHOOLS OF
THE DISTRICT FOR BICYCLE SAFETY
INSTRUCTIONS. HOWEVER THIS
SECTION HAS NOT BEEN UPDATED
SINCE ITS CREATION IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX. NOT ONLY DOES THIS
ALSO LEAVE OUT HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS. WHO COULD USE THIS
EDUCATION BUT IT HAS NOT KEPT UP
WITH THE INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGY
AND PRODUCTS FOR STUDENTS TO BE
EDUCATED. AND USING OUR
OPERATING. AB TWO ZERO TWO EIGHT
IT'S A SIMPLE MEASURE THAT WOULD
AMEND. EDUCATIONAL CO TO NOW
ALLOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS PARTNER
WITH NOT ONLY LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES. BUT ALSO OTHER PUBLIC.
SEES ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDE
TRAINING TO STUDENTS ON HOW TO
OPERATE BIKES. E. BIKES
MOTORIZED BIKES AND MOTORIZED
SCOOTERS. SINCE THEIR
INTRODUCTION TO THE MARKET
ELECTRIC BIKES E. BIKES AND
MOTORIZED SCOOTERS HAVE PROVIDED
COUNTLESS CALIFORNIA'S NEW
FREEDOMS AND MEANS OF
TRANSPORTATION AROUND CITIES AND
TOWNS. IN ADDITION TO THE
ACCEPTABILITY THESE PRODUCTS
HAVE ALSO PROVEN TO BE
ENVIRONMENTALLY. FRIENDLY AND
CHEAPER ALTERNATIVES TO DIESEL
POWERED CARS. ENSURING OUR NEXT
GENERATION HAS INFORMATION
OPERATIONAL EDUCATION. ON THESE
PRODUCTS. FOR HIS BEST INTEREST.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NOT A
SINGER AND OTHER FOR THE PUBLIC
IN SUPPORT. SEEING OTHER PERSON
IN THE PUBLIC ANY OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL SAYING OPPOSITION TO
THE COMMITTEE- ANY COMING
THROUGH THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
HAVE A MOTION. IT'S BEEN MOVED
BY THE VICE CHAIRMAN SECONDED BY
. MISTER BENNETT- PLEASE YOU MAY
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOT
VOTE. MISTER BENNETT'S SECOND.
OF I'VE JUST CONFIRMING YOU DO
YOU DO ACCEPT THE AMOUNT CORRECT
YES HE DOES ACCEPT THE MOMENT
YES UP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM SIX A. B. TWO ZERO TWO
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR-
DONALD HI DONALD HI SALLY.
VALLEY IS BENNETT. BENNETT I'D
CHEN CAN I PLEASE LEAI MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE QUIRK-SILVA. THE HAS
EXPOSED SO IT IS LIKE YOU THANK
YOU I'M TO OUR NEXT BILL IT'S A
FILE ITEM NINE AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY ONE BY MR GARCIA IS HERE
BUT. NINE MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR
ENTERTAINING A. B. TWO TO ONE.
THIS WOULD STRENGTHEN THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION RESOURCE
NETWORK ENSURE SPECIAL
EDUCATION. STUDENTS SUCCEED
WHILE MAINTAINING POSITIVE
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN THE
SCHOOLS AND OUR FAMILIES THIS
BILL WOULD SPECIFICALLY. FOCUS
ON STATEWIDE RESOURCES TO ASSIST
OUR FAMILIES AND OUR SCHOOLS GO
THROUGH THIS CAPACITY BUILDING.
EFFORT TO ENSURE THAT THE SYSTEM
OF SUPPORT- THAT IS PUT FORWARD
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION ACHIEVES
ITS OUTCOMES AND BUILD THE
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN THE SCHOOL
THE FAMILIES. THAT WE WANT TO
ALSO SEE TAKE PLACE FOR A GOOD
OUTCOME FOR THE STUDENTS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE BUT WE
DO HAVE TWO WITNESSES HERE
VERONICA COATS. THE SISTERS WERE
TENET THE HAMA COUNTY. AND CINDY
CHANDLER REGIONAL ALLIES ON FOR
FAMILY SO. THEY WILL BE BRIEF.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR O'DONNELL
AND VICE CHAIR DOLLY MY NAME IS
VERONICA COATS AND I AM THE
ASSISTANT SUPERINTENDENT OF TAME
A COUNTY SULFA AND A MEMBER OF
THE SELF ADMINISTRATORS OF
CALIFORNIA I'M HONORED TO BE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE. OUR LAST
BUDGET SAW HISTORIC INVESTMENTS
IN THE FORM OF A ONE TIME ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION FOR DISPUTE
PREVENTION TO ELEAZAR SELFIES
BECAUSE OF INCREASED SPECIAL
EDUCATION DISPUTES RELATED TO
PANDEMIC SCHOOL DISRUPTIONS. WE
KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAD
FOUR TIMES THE NATIONAL RATE OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION LITIGATION
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. WITH EVERY
DISPUTE WE RISK LOSING MUCH MORE
THAN DOLLARS RELATIONSHIP AND
TRUST WITH FAMILIES ARE DAMAGED
OUR TIME AND ATTENTION IS THEN
REFOCUS TOWARD LITIGATION. THE
INVESTMENTS LAST YEAR PROVIDED
MUCH NEEDED RESOURCES TO BEGIN-TRANSFORMING CALIFORNIA'S
CONTINUUM OF ALTERNATIVE DISPUTE
RESOLUTION AND PREVENTION BUT
MORE FUNDING AND EDUCATION ARE
NEEDED TO CONTINUE THIS WORK.
MANY OF US JUST RETURNED FROM
THE SOP ASSOCIATION'S ANNUAL
EIGHTY OUR CONFERENCE IT WAS
INSPIRING AS WE WITNESSED ACTUAL
EXAMPLES OF HOW THESE DOLLARS
ARE MAKING A DIFFERENCE IN REAL
TIME. THE CONFERENCE WAS WELL
ATTENDED BY EDUCATORS FAMILIES
AND ADVOCATES ALL DRIVEN TO
BUILD TRUST AND HEAL FROM THE
MANY IMPACTS OF THE LAST TWO
DIFFICULT YEARS. ADDITIONALLY A
SUB ASSOCIATE AS A SELF
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE PARTNERED
WITH THE STRAUS INSTITUTE AT
PEPPERDINE UNIVERSITY TO BRING
WORLD CLASS EPERTISE THE IEP
TEAMS. STRIP THE NATION IN
ALTERNATIVE DISPUTE RESOLUTION
AND ALREADY MULTIPLE CADRES OF
EDUCATORS HAVE BEEN TRAINED
USING METHODS ROOTED IN CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS COMPROMISED AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY EMPATHY. AB TWENTY
ONE TWENTY ONE WOULD PROVIDE A
LASTING FOUNDATION TO CONTINUE
THIS WORK STATEWIDE PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE HOPPED ALL
ELLIOTT'S. EXCEPTIONAL PART OF
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE IS THAT
IT'S REALLY WALKS THE WALK AND
BUILDING TRUSTING RELATIONSHIPS
AND ACKNOWLEDGES TO BUILD THE
MOST EFFECTIVE DISPUTE
PREVENTION FRAMEWORK FOR A
STATE. FAMILIES MUST BE PART OF
THE LEADERSHIP AND EDUCATION TO
THE FIELD AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
ONE WOULD REQUIRE A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN AN EDUCATIONAL AGENCY
AND A FAMILY AGENCY. FOR THIS
RESOURCE LEAD. THIS MODELS THE
EDUCATORS VALUE RELATIONSHIPS
TRUST AND HEALING TOGETHER THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
MY NAME IS CINDY CHANDLER FORMER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR FAMILY SU
FAMILY EMPOWERMENT CENTER
SERVING YUBA SUTTER AND COLUSA
COUNTIES. AND CURRENTLY ON THE
REGIONAL LIAISON. SO GOOD GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU CHAIR OF
DONALD THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF PARENTS. AND
FAMILIES IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
ONE TWENTY ONE. SOTHAT RECENT
FUNDING FOR THE EXPANSION OF THE
FAMILY AND POWERMAN CENTER STATE
WIDE. ALTERNATIVE DISPUTE
RESOLUTION PROJECTS AT OUR CELL
BELIEVES AND SPECIFIC
LEGISLATION. INCREASING STAFFING
AND DIVERSE LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES HAVE BEEN
RESPONSIVE AND CRITICAL. IN
SECURING THE BEST OUTCOMES FOR
OUR STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS
AND IT'S COME AT SUCH A
CHALLENGING AND COMPLEX TIME.
STUDENTS AND EDUCATORS ARE
REELING FROM THE EFFECTS OF
SOCIAL ISOLATION DISTANCE
LEARNING FINANCIAL HARDSHIP AND
MENTAL HEALTH IMPACTS. THESE
FUNDS ARE SO APPRECIATED. BUT AT
THIS TIME MORE IS NEEDED. IT'S
NO SURPRISE THAT EDUCATIONAL
TEAMS COMPOSED OF PARENTS
STUDENTS TEACHERS ADMINISTRATORS
AND SUPPORT STAFF NEED
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES TO COME
TOGETHER TO BUILD TRUST IN THE
SYSTEM TO RESOLVE THOSE
DISAGREEMENTS DISPUTES AND
CONTESTED RULINGS. THE MAGIC OF
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE IS IN-THE COLLABORATIVE MAKE UP FROM
ITS INCEPTION IT'S NOT A MODEL
WHERE THE PROJECT IS DEVELOPED
BY PROFESSIONALS WITHOUT PARENTS
AND PARENT ORGANIZATIONS. AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE WILL
ENSURE FROM GROUND ZERO THE
PARENTS ARE INCLUDED TO HELP
CREATE A STUDENT FOCUSED PATH
THE RESOLUTION THROUGH PARENTS
SUPPORT. AND PARTICIPATION.
THROUGH COLLABORATION ACTIVE AND
SAFE COMMUNICATION HONESTY AND
TRUST. THE OTHER PARENT
TRAININGS HAVE REACHED INTO
COMMUNITIES RURAL URBAN AND
ACROSS ECONOMIC SECTORS. AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REACH FURTHER AND
DEEPER HAND IN HAND WITH PARENTS
WITH EQUITY AND DIVERSITY AS KEY
IN BUILDING TRUST AND RESOLUTION
THE PLEASE VOTE YES ON AB TWENTY
ONE TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU OTHER
IN SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON
ELIZABETH ANGLE CAN REPRESENTING
THE US SELL BOTH THE SUCCESSFUL
EDUCATION LOCAL PLAN AREA
ADMINISTRATORS OF CALIFORNIA AND
LOCALLY IN MY LOCAL REGION THE
YOLO COUNTY SULFA AND OUR
COMMUNITY ADVISORY COMMITTEE
CHAIRED BY OUR PARENTS. STRONG
SUPPORT. GREAT I SEEN OTHERS IN
SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. NO OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
I DO WE HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO HAVE A
MOTION. BUT BY MR LI. SECOND MY
MISTER BENNETT. THE MOVE IN
SECOND YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN I WANTED KNOWLEDGE
THE WORK OF YOUR COMMITTEE TEAM.
FOR HELP IN A SUB BRING THIS
BILL FORWARD CLEARLY KNOWLEDGE
THE TESTIMONY THAT YOU JUST
HEARD THANK THEM AS WELL
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU. I WITH THAT. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
NINE AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS DONALD. HI DONALD
I DALLI. DALLI II BENNETT.
BENNETT AYE CHEN. CAN I PLEASE.
LEAVE I MCCARTY. RTI QUIRK-SILVA
. QUIRK-SILVA I HAVE BEEN BOTH
THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTE SO IT IS
OUT THANK YOU HEY MISTER AND I
THINK YOU'RE TO STAY HERE
PRESENTED WITH INFORMATION YEAH
RIGHT SIR THE OVER READY TO YOU
MAY PROCEED ONE READY WE'RE
GOING TO- FILE ITEM FOURTEEN
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN. WHICH IS A
J. R. EIGHT I ACTUALLY BY MISS
RIVAS. ON BEHALF OF A SOME
MEMBER THREE OF US PRESENTING A
J. R. EIGHT THE RESOLUTION
BEFORE YOU WHAT ARE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO PROVIDE SCHOOL
LUNCHES FREE OF CHARGE TO ALL
ELEMENTARY MIDDLE SCHOOL. AND
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS IN THE
UNITED STATES- THIS BUILDS OFF
OF HER PUBLIC POLICY WORK LAST
YEAR WERE. BUDGET INCLUDED MONEY
TO ENSURE THAT THIS HAPPENED IN
CALIFORNIA. DUE TO EXPIRE IN
JUNE THIS YEAR WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT LOW AND VERY
LOW INCOME. FAMILIES AND
STUDENTS OF CALIFORNIA SPECT WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ANYWAY THIS IS IN SUPPORT. ANY
PERSONS IN OPPOSITION NO. I
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS OR ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. NOW DO WE DO IN MOTION.
MR LEE AND MR BENNETT SECONDS.
ARE WITH THAT- YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION ON
THIS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
SUPPORT. THIS CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AJ R. EIGHT
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR O'DONNELL HI
DONNA HI SALLY SALLY I SENATE.
BENNETT I CHEN N. I. LI LI I
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE QUIRK-SILVA
. QUIRK-SILVA I. THE BILL HAS
SEVEN VOTED OUT THANK YOU WITH
THAT WE'RE GOING TO ASK A
CARILLO I WILL GO TO A FINE
NUMBER ELEVEN. ELEVEN IS AB.
TWENTY THREE TWENTY NINE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
AM PROUD TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
THREE TO TWENTY NINE WHICH WOULD
MAKE IT EASIER FOR CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO CONNECT
FAMILIES IN NEED WITH NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY VISION PROVIDERS SO
THAT THEY CAN RECEIVE A FULL
VISION EXAM AND GLASSES AFTER A
REFERRAL FROM A SCHOOL NURSE. UP
280% OF THE INFORMATION A CHILD
IS PRESENTED WITHIN THE
CLASSROOM IS VISUAL AND STUDIES
SHOW THAT INTERVENTION TO
CORRECT THE CHILD'S VISION
PROBLEM HAVE IMMEDIATE POSITIVE
LEARNING OUTCOMES A CHILD COPING
WITH AN UNCORRECTED VISION
PROBLEM WILL LIKELY NOT ONLY
EXPERIENCE LEARNING PROBLEMS BUT
DISENGAGEMENT FROM
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES AS
WELL. THEY COULD EVEN EXPERIENCE
PHYSICAL PAIN SUCH AS HEADACHES
AND FATIGUE. INTERCEPTS BETWEEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITY
VISION PROVIDERS ARE ALREADY
HAPPENING AND ARE INCREDIBLY
SUCCESSFUL. SCHOOL NURSES ARE
TASKED WITH CONDUCTING VISION
SCREENINGS AND WHERE THESE
PARTNERSHIPS EXIST THE SCHOOL
NURSE CAN THEN REFERRED THE
STUDENT TO THE PROVIDER FOR A
FULL EXAM AND GLASSES IF A
PROBLEM. IS IDENTIFIED WHEN THIS
HAPPENS FAMILIES IN NEED ARE
RECEIVING A- SPECIALTY SERVICE
FREE OF CHARGE THAT THEY MAY NOT
OTHERWISE BE ABLE TO ACCESS.
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE. THE TO
SUCH A MEANINGFUL INTERVENTION
LIKE THAT TO A CHILD IN MY
COMMUNITY IS SOMETHING THAT I.
CARE VERY DEEPLY ABOUT IN IS
VERY PERSONAL TO ME. HOWEVER
THERE IS A POINT OF FRICTION
THAT WE NEED TO REMOTE. AND THAT
IS THE PARENTS MUST OPT IN. ON A
FORM THAT MUST BE RETURNED FOR
THE EXAM. VISION EXAMS ARE NON
INVASIVE PROVIDER SOME BACK ARE
ALREADY BACKGROUND CHECKED. AND
RECALL AS REQUIRED BY EXISTING
LAW AND SERVICES ARE PROVIDED
WITH DISTRICT STAFF PRESENT THIS
BILL WILL STILL ENSURE THAT
PARENTS ARE INFORMED OF THE
AVAILABILITY. OF A VISION EXAM
FROM A COMMUNITY PROVIDER
HOWEVER. WE JUST CANNOT ACCEPT
THE FATE OF A CHILD'S LEARNING
OUTCOMES MAY REST ON A MISPLACED
PIECE OF PAPERWORK. I'M GRATEFUL
TO HAVE TWO WITNESSES HERE THAT
SERVE MY COMMUNITY AND CAN TALK
MORE ABOUT THIS BILL. I WILL LET
THEM INTRODUCE THEMSELVES. AT.
SYSTEM AT THE IT SHOULD BE A
WHITE BUT NO THIS IS MIKE OKAY.
ENOUGH ABOUT IT. I'M GOOD
AFTERNOON CHERO DONNELL AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
MERRY JANE PUFFER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE LOS ANGELES
TRUST FOR CHILDREN'S HEALTH. I
REPRESENT AN INDEPENDENT BIBLE
ONE SEE THREE SEPARATE JUST
HEALTH AND EDUCATION TO ACHIEVE
STUDENT WELLNESS. WE EFFECTIVELY
WORK WITH SCHOOL STAFF AND
COMMUNITY PARTNERS TO INTEGRATE
CHILD HEALTH SERVICES. AND
PROVIDE PREVENTION EDUCATION ON
SCHOOL CAMPUSES BECAUSE WE KNOW
DISTRICTS CAN'T DO THIS ALONE.
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT AND AN
ALLIANCE WITH- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO THAT THERE ARE PROVIDERS
READY TO SERVE. SUPPORT FOR OPT
OUT EXAMS FOR VISION IS CRITICAL
FOR VULNERABLE FAMILIES. WILL BE
SCREENING MAY BE THE FIRST AND
ONLY WAY THAT VISUAL COMPROMISE
CAN BE DIAGNOSED. EARNING AN
EXAMS ARE PUBLIC HEALTH STRATEGY
THAT SUPPORTS THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH AND IN
THIS CASE THAT SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS IS EDUCATION. DUNCE
HAPPENS UNIVERSITY CONDUCTED A
CLINICAL TRIAL FROM TWENTY
SIXTEEN TO TWENTY NINETEEN
ANALYZING THE PERFORMANCE OF TWO
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND FOR
STUDENTS IN GRADES THREE TO
SEVEN. WHO RECEIVE SCREENINGS I
EXAMS AND GLASSES. FOR
CHILDREN'S RECEIVING FOR
CHILDREN RECEIVING GLASSES
READING SCORES INCREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER ONE YEAR AND
COMPARED TO THOSE WITH GLASSES
AND SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT WAS
SEEN IN ALL MATH AND ALL
ELEMENTARY GRADES. THE CIVIC
IMPROVEMENT FOR GIRLS AND
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS AND
THE LOWEST PERFORMING STUDENTS
WAS EVIDENCED AND ATTEMPT IT
MADE A MORE LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
FOR CHILDREN IN THESE CATEGORIES
. MORE THAN 20% OF SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN IN THE UNITED STATES
HAVE VISION PROBLEMS I DON'T
WANT STUDENTS ARE TWO TO THREE
TIMES MORE LIKELY THAN NINETY
NINE TITLE ONE STUDENTS TO HAVE
AN UNDETECTED OR UNTREATED
VISION PROBLEMS. REQUIRING
PARENTAL CONSENT FOR NO COST
VISION EXAMS CREATES AN
UNNECESSARY BARRIER FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN. UNLIMITED
ACCESS TO CARE BETWEEN SCHOOLS
AND VISION PROVIDERS. PARENTS
MAY FORGET TO OR CANNOT RETURN
THE PAPERWORK FOR A MYRIAD OF
REASONS. BUT CHILDREN'S HEALTH
SHOULD NOT PRE PAY THE PRICE. AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY NINE REMOVES
THOSE BARRIERS TO KERR. AND
GRANTS ACCESS TO ESSENTIAL
VISION VISION EXAMS. FOR THESE
REASONS THE LOS ANGELES TRUST
FOR CHILDREN'S HEALTH IS IN FULL
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY NINE AND WE HOPE FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU TO THE NEXT
WHAT THE WITNESS GOOD AFTERNOON-
CHAIR O'DONNELL AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ON WILL SALAS DEAN
I AM THE DIRECTOR OF WELLNESS
PROGRAMS FOR THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. BEFORE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
ON SUCH AN IMPORTANT TOPIC FOR
OUR DISTRICT AND OUR STUDENTS.
ALL SENSES UNIFIED IS PLEASED TO
SPONSOR ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE TWENTY NINE WHICH WOULD
AUTHORIZE SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
ENTER INTO A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING WITH THE VISION
EXAMINATION PROVIDER- AND ALLOWS
PARENTS TO OPT OUT. SCHOOL I
HELP PROGRAMS INCLUDE SCHOOL
BASS VISION SCREENINGS WHICH ARE
ADMINISTERED BY OUR SCHOOL
NURSES. A REFERRALS FOR EYE
EXAMS THAT ARE EITHER SCHOOL
BASED OR AN OUTSIDE
ORGANIZATION. IN AN EYE GLASSES
ARE DELIVERED. TO UNDERSCORE
THIS POINT AN INCREASE IN VISION
EXAMS DOES NOT TAKE WORK AWAY
FROM OUR SCHOOL NURSES SAYS THEY
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE INITIAL
SCREENINGS. IN THE EYE EXAMS ARE
CONDUCTED BY OPTOMETRISTS. THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED EVERY
STUDENT RECEIVES A VISION
SCREENING A SPECIFIC GRADES AS
REQUIRED BY CURRENT LAW. HOWEVER
WHEN IT COMES TO VISION EXAM
STUDENTS ARE EITHER REFERRED TO
OUTSIDE PROVIDERS ARE OFFERED
SERVICES WITHIN A SCHOOL BY A
VISION PROVIDER. WHILE I CONSENT
IS NOT REQUIRED FOR SCREENING.
CAROL CONSENT IS REQUIRED FOR AN
EYE EXAMINATION. WELL SENDS
UNIFIED FUNDS ONE FULL TIME AND
TWO PART TIME OPTOMETRIST TO
PROVIDE FREE VISION EXAMS AND
GLASSES TO STUDENTS AT A FEW OF
OUR SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CLINICS.
VISION PROVIDERS WHO HAVE
ESTABLISHED A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING WITH LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED ALSO PROVIDE FREE EYE
EXAMS AND GLASSES TO STUDENTS.
THE GOAL OF AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY NINE IS TO PROVIDE MORE
STUDENTS ACCESS TO NO COST
VISION EXAMS BY ALLOWING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO ENTER INTO A
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING WITH
THE VISION EXAMINATION PROVIDER.
AND THEN PROVIDE A REASONABLE
AMOUNT OF TIME TO GIVE PARENTS
THE OPTION TO OPT OUT OF THE
SCHEDULE VISION EXAM. BODY'S
EXAM PROCEDURES ARE IN NON
INVASIVE PARENTS WILL HAVE A
CHOICE TO OPT OUT. IN ADDITION
IT'S BILLS PERMISSIVE BUT THOSE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT DESIRE TO
OFFER THESE PROGRAMS AND US IT
DOES NOT CREATE A MANDATE IF
DISTRICTS CHOOSE NOT TO LEVERAGE
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL. IF
THE BILL PASSES LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED IS HOPING TO DEVELOP A
CONSENT. THERE WILL BE AN
ELECTRONIC FORMAT IN ORDER TO
ALLOW PARENTS AND CARE GIVERS TO
EASILY ACCESS INFORMATION
REGARDING THE AVAILABLE SERVICES
AND TO PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
DOCUMENTS PLEASE SUMMARIZE.
INCLUDING INCLUDING IN THE OPT
OUT FORM. AND SO WITH THAT AGAIN
LAW SAYS UNIFIED IS PROUD TO
SPONSOR AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY
NINE AND WE URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
FOR THIS IMPORTANT BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. SEE NO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. SIGNOFF POSITION RIVER
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY COMMENTS ABOUT IT. BILL
MAKES A LOT OF COMMON SENSE
THANK YOU BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
A MOVE RECOMMENDED ACTION. MOVED
AND SECONDED- ANY OTHERS. WE
GATHER COMMENT COMMITTEE
COMMENTS NOW WITH THAT ARE YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- I JUST WANNA SAY TO THE
MEMBERS OF THIS BODY INTO THE
LEGISLATURE WE HAVE DONE A LOT
OF INVESTMENT AND CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ACTUALLY KATE THROUGH TWELVE
PRESCHOOL AFTER SCHOOL AND
ESPECIALLY THE WORK DONE TO
ENSURE THAT. ALL OF THAT SUPPORT
AN OPPORTUNITY IS AVAILABLE TO
ALL STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF
SOCIAL ECONOMIC STATUS
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS ARE LANGUAGE
THAT THEY MAY SPEAK AT HOME BUT
WHAT DOES IT ALL MEAN OR DOES IT
EVEN MATTER IF AT THE END OF THE
DAY A CHILD SIMPLY CANNOT SEE
THE BOARD IN FRONT OF THEM THE
BOOK IN FRONT OF THEM AND CAN'T
HAVE ACCESS TO LEARNING BECAUSE
THEY SIMPLY CANNOT READ THE
WORDS IN FRONT OF THEM. I HAVE
BEEN IN THE CLASSROOM I HAVE PUT
GLASSES ON A CHILD AND HAVE SEEN
THAT CHILD COMPLETELY TRANSFORM
. EVERYTHING THAT WE DO. AT IS
ALL ABOUT THE NEXT GENERATION OF
CALIFORNIANS. AND UNLESS WE DO
SOMETHING ABOUT A CHILD'S
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO READ AND
SEE THE BOARD AND SEE THE WORK
IN FRONT OF THEM. WHAT ARE WE
DOING. SO THIS IS A GOOD
COMMONSENSE APPROACH. THESE
PARTNERSHIPS ALREADY EXIST. AND
MISTER CHAIR OF MOMENT PRIVILEGE
I JUST WANNA THANK YOU FOR ALL
OF YOUR WORK. AT CHAIRING THIS
COMMITTEE THIS MAY BE THE LAST
TIME THAT I PRESENT A BILL-
BEFORE YOU LEAVE THIS BODY SO
THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING YOU'VE
DONE TO AND THAT'S- THE NEEDS OF
EDUCATION FOR ALL OF OUR KIDS
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY NINE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE O'DONNELL HI
DONNA I DALLI. DALLI I. BENNETT
BENNETT AYE CHAN CHAN I LI. LI I
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE QUIRK-SILVA
. QUIRK-SILVA I'D- THE BILL HAS
SEVEN VOTES IT IS OUT THANK YOU
THINK ABOUT OUR THAT WILL NOW GO
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SEVEN WELL
I'M TWELVE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT OUR
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
SEVEN AND A FRIEND OF THE
COMMITTEE TEAR TODAY. I WOULD
LIKE. TO BEGIN BY THANKING
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS MEASURE AND BY ACCEPTING
THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BILL INTO
UNTIL THE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE ACADEMICS A YEAR. AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SEVEN WEST OF
WILL STARTING IN TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE ACADEMIC YEAR
LOWERED THE AGE OF WHICH POST
SECONDARY TRANSITION PLANNING
FOR STUDENTS WITH EXCEPTIONAL
NEEDS BEGINS FROM. AGE SIXTEEN
DOWN TO AGE FOURTEEN FOR MANY
YOUTH WITH AUTISM AND OTHER
DISABILITIES THE TRANSITION TO
ADULTHOOD BEGINS WITH AN
INTERVAL INDIVIDUALIZED
EDUCATION PLAN OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS AN I. E. P. UNDER CURRENT
CALIFORNIA LAW. PLANNING IS NOT
REQUIRED TO BEGIN UNTIL AGE
SIXTEEN WHEN MANY STUDENTS ARE
IN THEIR JUNIOR YEAR AS A RESULT
THE STATE IS NOT PROVIDING
STUDENTS WHO HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS HAVING A
DISABILITY WHAT THE ESSENTIAL
TIME NEEDED TO DEVELOP
APPROPRIATE SKILLS FOR ADULT
LIFE. AND THE TIME FOR SCHOOLS-
PARENTS INSISTED SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO DEVELOP IT IS TIME
I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT IT IS TIME
FOR STORE. FIRST- FOR US SCHOOLS
PARENTS AND SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
DEVELOP MEANINGFUL
INDIVIDUALIZED TRANSITION PLANS.
TO THAT END THE BUDGET ACT OF
TWENTY TWENTY ESTABLISHED A
STATEWIDE IP WORKING GROUP TO
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
IMPROVE. THE PROCESS FOR
DEVELOPING IEPS FOR STUDENTS
WERE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE SPECIAL
EDUCATION ND RELATED SERVICES.
THE WORKING GROUP DEVELOPED
TWENTY FIVE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
IMPROVE THE IP PROCESS. AND TO
ENSURE THAT IT PEAS ARE DESIGNED
AND- ARE DESIGNED TO ENHANCE
STUDENT OUTCOMES. THIS INCLUDES
RECORD I THIS INCLUDED- A
RECOMMENDATION FOR CALIFORNIA
STATE LEGISLATURE TO REVISE THE
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION CODE. TO
ADJUST THE REQUIRED AGE FOR
BEGINNING POST SECONDARY
TRANSITION PLANNING FROM EIGHT
SIXTEEN TWO EIGHT FOURTEEN. I
AND NOTED THAT MOST US STATES
AND TERRITORIES BEGIN TRANSITION
PLANNING AT AGE FOURTEEN. AB TWO
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SEVEN WILL
DO JUST THAT. FINALLY RESEARCH
HAS DEMONSTRATED THAT SPECIFIC
STRATEGIES AND IP'S CAN HELP
STUDENTS WITH INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES PURSUE HIGHER
EDUCATION AND LIVE MORE
INDEPENDENTLY AFTER GRADUATION.
BY IMPLEMENTING THESE STRATEGIES
TWO YEARS EARLIER CALIFORNIA
WILL BEGIN TO SEE IMPROVED LONG
TERM OUTCOMES. YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR OUR VOTE
AND I DO HAVE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MELISSA
CORTEZ ON BEHALF OF AUTISM
SPEAKS WHO IS THE SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL ALSO REGISTERING
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER
FOR AUTISM AND RELATED
DISORDERS- AS THE ANALYSIS NOTED
EARLIER TRANSITION PLANNING IS
SUPPORTED BY A VARIETY OF
STUDIES THAT SHOW HIGHER
EMPLOYMENT RATES. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO MENTIONED THE-
STATE BUDGET BUDGET ACT AND TO
THE WORKING GROUP WITH THAT
RECOMMENDED THE AGE BE LOWERED
TO FOURTEEN- THAT WORK GROUP WAS
COMPRISED OF REPRESENTATIVES
FROM C. D. E. THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION. THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
ELEAZER CELLPHONES AND OTHER
RELEVANT EXPERTS SO REALLY THE
PEOPLE WHO KNOW ABOUT THIS
POLICY WHO WERE IN THE WEEDS AND
ARE LOOKING. AT WHAT THE BEST
POSSIBLE OUTCOMES COULD BE MADE
THIS RECOMMENDATION- LOWERING
THE AGE TRANSITION PLANNING WILL
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL TIME TO
IDENTIFY THE STUDENTS READINESS
FOR AND STRENGTH RELATED TO. THE
MANY TYPES OF TRANSITIONS IN THE
I. E. P. IT'S ALSO CONSISTENT
WITH EXISTING LAW WHICH STATES
THAT PLANNING FOR TRANSITION FOR
SCHOOL TO POSTSECONDARY
ENVIRONMENTS SHOULD BEGIN IN THE
SCHOOL SYSTEM WELL BEFORE THE
STUDENT LEAVES WITHOUT ALL THE
FOR THE REST OF MY TIME TO KELLY
HAS WORKED WITH. AUTISM SPEAKS.
THANK HIM THANK HIM- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO. MISTER CHAIRMAN AS
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M KELLY HAD TO COME
ON THE STAFF OF AUTISM SPEAKS
AND IF YOU'RE NOT FAMILIAR WITH
US WE'RE A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION. THAT IS IN SUPPORT
OF THE AUTISM COMMUNITY. OUR
MAIN ACTIVITIES ARE TO FIND
RESEARCH- PROVIDE DIRECT SUPPORT
AND SERVICES. I'M PROMOTE
AWARENESS AND ACCEPTANCE OF
AUTISM AND ADVOCATE AT THE
FEDERAL AND STATE LEVELS ON A
REALLY FOCUSED SET OF PUBLIC
POLICY PRIORITIES. AMONG THESE A
SPECIAL EDUCATION INCLUDING THAT
REALLY IMPORTANT TIME FROM-
ARTISTIC STUDENTS TRANSITION
FROM PRIMARY AND SECONDARY
EDUCATION TO ADULT LIFE. AS
YOU'VE HEARD STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT QUALITY TRANSITION PLANNING
WHICH STARTS AS EARLY AS
POSSIBLE IN HIGH SCHOOL. AND
INCLUDES A KEY FOCUS ON PAID
WORK INTERNSHIPS
APPRENTICESHIPS- AND OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES IS CORRELATED WITH
BETTER OUTCOMES IN THEIR ADULT
LIVES. ADDITION PLANNING SHOULD
INVOLVE THE STUDENT AND THEIR IP
TEAM VOCATIONAL REHABILITATION
STAFF AND OTHERS WHO CAN HELP
THEM- PLAN THAT THE STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES PLAN FOR
RELEVANT. A POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION HOUSING EMPLOYMENT AND
SERVICE NEEDS. A MAJORITY OF
STATES USE FOURTEEN NOW AS THE
AGE- TO REQUIRED START OF
PLANNING AND AS YOU'VE HEARD
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY IS THAT
SIXTEEN. WHICH IS TYPICALLY
SOPHOMORE TO JUNIOR YEAR SOME
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO ARCTIC SEA
THIS- IN CALIFORNIA. STUDENTS
WITH AUTISM AND OTHER
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES OFTEN
NEED ADDITIONAL PREPARATION AND
ADJUSTMENT TIME THAN THEIR
NEUROTYPICAL PEERS AND- THIS
BILL WOULD HELP ADDRESS BATS.
I'M GONNA SKI I WAS GONNA TAKE A
LITTLE BIT OF A STORY BUT YOU
HAVE A VERY LONG AGENDA SO I'M
GOING TO SKIP THAT AND JUST SAY
THAT- WITH GOOD PLANNING AND
PREPARATION SOME STUDENTS WILL
BE ABLE TO ATTEND COLLEGE OR
OTHER HIGHER EDUCATION MANY CAN
WORK WITH OR WITHOUT
ACCOMMODATIONS. I EVEN AS THEY
MAY HAVE CONTINUING SERVICE
NEEDS- AND- WE STRONGLY OR TO
THE BILL AND URGE AND I VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. I SEE NO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. NO OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS FOR MANY
THAT COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WE HAVE
A MOTION. AND MOVED BY THE VICE
CHAIR AND SECOND WHY. YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU AS A FORMER
TEACHER AND A MOTHER OF A
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD I CAN TELL YOU
THAT- REGULAR EDUCATION STUDENTS
NEED THIS AS WELL SO- I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I BOUGHT. THANK YOU A
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
TWELVE AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL I'VE DONE ALL I DALLI.
DALLI I'D BENNETT. BENNETT I
CHEN N. I. LI. LEAI MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE QUIRK-SILVA
QUIRK-SILVA I. AS SEVERAL
SERVICE OUT THANK YOU. WITH THAT
MOVE WILL NOT FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN AB TWO ZERO FIVE EIGHT
BY O'DONNELL'S ANIL TURN OVER TO
THE VICE CHAIR.
AND. A READY MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU THANK YOU MATTER CHERRY
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB TWO ZERO
FIVE EIGHT WHICH WILL STREAMLINE
K. TWELVE CT PROGRAMS BY
CONSOLIDATING TWO FUNDING
STREAMS INTO A SINGLE PROGRAM AT
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR AND INCREASE
THE LEVEL OF REGIONAL SUPPORT
FOR THESE PROGRAMS. HIGH QUALITY
CTE PROGRAMS IN OUR SCHOOLS ARE
CRITICAL TO ENSURE THAT STUDENTS
GAIN THE SKILLS THEY NEED TO
ENTER THE WORKFORCE OR EMBARK ON
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION AND
TRAINING. THE STRENGTH OF
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY DEPENDS
UPON A SKILLED WORKFORCE AND CTE
PROGRAMS ARE AN ESSENTIAL PART
OF BUILDING THAT WORKFORCE.
CURRENTLY SCHOOLS ARE REQUIRED
TO APPLY TO TWO SEPARATE
PROGRAMS TO FUND THEIR CTE
COURSES AND PATHWAYS. THE CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION INCENTIVE
GRANT PROGRAM FOR SEATED AS WE
CALL AROUND HERE. AT CD THAT'S
WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION WHICH TYPICALLY
HANDLES K. TWELVE MONEY- THE US
STRONG WORK FORCE MONEY IS
HANDLED BY THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE. I'VE I'VE DID I BELIEVE
IT IS NOT APPROPRIATE FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO BE
ADMINISTERING A K. TWELVE
PROGRAM AND I REQUESTED AN AUDIT
OF THE PROGRAM LAST YEAR THE
THE AUDIT OF THE K. TWELVE
STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM THAT'S
THE ONE ADMINISTERED BY THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE- THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. THE AUDIT
FOUND SEVERAL SHORTCOMINGS IN
THE STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM
INCLUDING THE FOLLOWING LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY IN THE APPLICATION
OF GRANT SELECTION PROCESS LACK
OF EQUAL ACCESS TO LOCAL SUPPORT
STAFF AS THERE IS ONE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDER. FOR EACH OF
THE SEVENTY TWO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS REGARDLESS OF
HOW MANY ELEAZAR ARE WITHIN THAT
DISTRICT. SOME SELECTION
COMMITTEES WERE FOUND TO HAVE
INSUFFICIENT SAFEGUARDS AGAINST
UNFAIR GRANT DECISIONS DUE TO
INCONSISTENT SCORING. AS WELL AS
AN INHERENT CONFLICT OF INTEREST
AS MEMBERS OF. THE SELECTION
COMMITTEES MAY WORK FOR ELLIE AS
APPLYING FOR GRANTS. OR CLEAR
CONFLICT OF CONFLICT THERE AB
TWO ZERO FIVE EIGHT ADDRESSES
MANY OF THESE ISSUES BY
COMBINING BOTH PROGRAM PROGRAMS
INTO THE EXISTING SEATED PROGRAM
UNDER CD. THIS WILL REDUCE THE
BURDEN ON ELEAZAR BY REQUIRING A
SINGLE APPLICATION AND THEN
ANNUAL REPORT RATHER THAN
MULTIPLE APPLICATIONS AND
MULTIPLE REPORTS. ELEAZAR WILL
BE ABLE TO MAXIMIZE THE USE OF
THEIR AVAILABLE MATCH FUNDS BY
DEDICATING THEM TO A SINGLE
APPLICATION. RATHER THAN TRYING
TO BALANCE BETWEEN TWO PROGRAMS.
APPLICATIONS WILL BE SCORED
CONSISTENTLY AT THE STATE LEVEL
THEREBY AVOIDING CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
FINALLY TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
WILL BE PROVIDED ON A REGIONAL
BASIS BY K. TWELVE EDUCATORS
FAMILIAR WITH THE ROLE OF C. T.
E. WITHIN THE K. TWELVE SYSTEM.
THESE CHANGES WILL ENSURE THAT
STATE FUNDS CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
HIGH QUALITY CTE PROGRAMS AN
EQUITABLE WAY. AND HERE TO SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF THE AB TWO ZERO
FIVE EIGHT R. DR BARBER AND I'M
CO SUPERINTENDENT NAPPY KIDNAP
ACCOUNTING COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. AND MERRY. A RESIDENT
WHY DID US CG COORDINATOR AT THE
MERCED COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. THANK YOU I CAN THROW
THIS AWAY THE ASSEMBLY MEN SO
THE PERFECTLY IT'S ALL IN THE
BILL- HONESTLY I HAVE NEVER
UNDERSTOOD WHY THE MONEY WAS
BIFURCATED IN THE FIRST PLACE
WHY WOULD YOU TAKE MONEY FOR ONE
PARTICULAR AREA AND MAKE PEOPLE
WRITE TWO SEPARATE APPLICATIONS
TO TWO DIFFERENT AGENCIES THE
STRONG WORK FORCE APPLICATION
THROUGH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
PARTICULARLY CUMBERSOME. AND
THEN YOU HAVE TO WRITE REPORTS
TO DO DIFFERENT AGENCIES AND
EVALUATIONS IF I'M SORRY IT'S
MADNESS- WE REALLY WANT TO SEE
THE MONEY BACK WITH THE PEOPLE
WHO UNDERSTAND CTE PROGRAMS K.
TWELVE. ALSO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HOLD BACK 30% OF THE
MONEY UNTIL YOU'VE SPENT THE
OTHER MONEY FIRST WHICH MAKES NO
SENSE TO ANY OF US AND THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY MONEY IN THEIR-
THEIR PROCESS FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR TEACHERS SO IT'S
ALL VERY NICE TO HAVE SOME KIND
OF- FOR PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
FOR ADMINISTRATORS BUT THE
RUBBER MEETS THE ROAD IN THE
CLASSROOM. NO I KNOW YOU ALL
SUPPORT C. D. E. AND YOU KNOW
THAT WITHOUT THAT KIDS GRADUATE
FROM HIGH SCHOOL AND THEY ARE
CLUELESS ABOUT WHAT THEY WANT TO
DO AFTER HIGH SCHOOL WHAT ARE
YOU DOING NEXT YEAR I'M GOING TO
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE WHAT DO
YOU STUDYING I DON'T KNOW. HE TO
TAKE C. T. E. NO THEY HAVE AN
IDEA AND MAYBE THE IDEA IS THEY
KNOW WHAT THEY DON'T WANT TO DO
BUT THAT'S GOOD TOO BECAUSE YOUR
PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS NEED
SOMEONE TO SPEND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS OR MORE SENDING THEM TO
COLLEGE TO MAJOR IN SOMETHING
THAT THEN THEY FIND OUT THEY
DON'T WANT TO DO. CZ IS CRITICAL
LET'S MAKE IT EASIER FOR OUR
ELEAZAR TO GET THE MONEY AND TO
RUN FOR PROGRAMS LET'S NOT MAKE
IT HARDER DID YOU THINK WE
DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH PAPERWORK YOU
KNOW IN OUR OFFICE WE. CALL THE
LAST TWO YEARS PLAN DEMOCRATS.
SO I SUPPORT THIS THAT MORE THAN
I CAN SAY THANK YOU TELL. JOB
WELL THAT'S GONNA BE HARD TO
FOLLOW. I'M AS I WAS INTRODUCED
MERRY WHY DID COORDINATOR- FOR
THE MERCED COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL
PROGRAM PAST PRESIDENT OF THE C.
A. R. O. C. P. AND ASSOCIATION
CURRENT COLLEGE READINESS AND
PRESIDENT ELECT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CAREER
AND TECHNICAL EDUCATION. I'M
HONORED TO HAVE DEDICATED THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS IN THE
CLASSROOM AND IN ADMINISTRATION
TO THE WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITIES
AND ENHANCEMENT CITY BRINGS
DECADES TWELVE STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK THE C. T.
FILLED IS GRATEFUL FOR THE
SUPPORT AND THE DECISIONS THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER R. DONNELL AND
THIS COMMITTEE HAVE MADE TO
BUILD BACK C. T. FUNDING AFTER
L. CFF. PRIOR TO THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF K. TWELVE
STRONG WORK FORCE. CO EASE THE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION'S AND
COOPERATIONS WITH CDP WERE
RESPONSIBLE PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO ELLIE AS-
REGARDING THEIR CTE PROGRAMS AND
PATHWAYS. THIS WAS A NATURAL
ROLE FOR CO EASE ESPECIALLY IN
MY ORGANIZATION AND FOR THOSE CO
YOU TO CONTINUE TO RUN
TRADITIONAL RO PIECE. MANY OF
THE C. ALWAYS PROVIDE SUPPORT IN
ADDITION TO FUNDING SEVERAL CTE
PATHWAYS NOT ONLY TO LARGER
DISTRICTS BUT TO SMALLER AND
RURAL SCHOOLS. THROUGHOUT OUR
COUNTIES. C. ALWAYS HAVE A DEEP
UNDERSTANDING EXPERTISE AND
HISTORY OF K. TWELVE C. T. WITH
LONGSTANDING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
CD AND ELLIE ACE IN THEIR
COUNTIES. THIS FAMILIAR
RELATIONSHIP POSITIONS THEM TO
PROVIDE EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT
SUPPORT OF CTE PROGRAMS PATHWAYS
AND THEIR REGIONAL AREA. THE
TRANSITION TO K. TWELVE STRONG
WORK FORCE TECHNICAL SYSTEM
MODEL HAS CAUSED SOME CONFUSION
AND MISCOMMUNICATION IN THE
FIELD. WITH SOMETIMES MULTIPLE
K. TWELVE STRONG WORKFORCE
PATHWAY COORDINATOR SERVING ONE
COUNTY MESSAGES ARE OFTEN
DILUTED CONTRADICTORY OR MISSING
TO SOME ELLIE ACE. THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDED UNDER THE
CURRENT MODEL DO NOT ALWAYS HAVE
THE SAME LEVEL OF EXPERTISE OR
HAVE THE RELATIONSHIPS AND ARE
IN EQUITABLY DISTRIBUTED. WITH
SOME COORDINATORS HAVING TEN
ALLEY AS WHILE OTHER SERVE UP TO
THIRTY EIGHT. THIS MODEL
CONCENTRATES ON COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS RATHER THAN K.
TWELVE DISTRICTS LEAVING SOME OF
OUR RULE SCHOOLS WITHOUT THE
SAME OPPORTUNITIES AND
INFORMATION OF OTHER SCHOOLS IN
OUR COUNTY. INSTANCE UNDER THE
CURRENT CURRENT MODEL TO A
MERCED COUNTY HIGH SCHOOLS LOST%
LONGSTANDING ARTICULATIONS AND
EARLY CLLEGE CREDIT
OPPORTUNITIES BECAUSE OF THEIR
LOCATION BASED ON THE COMMUNITY
DISTRICT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT LINES. THERE'S BEEN A
LACK OF DIRECTION FOR MANY
PATHWAY COORDINATORS LEADING TO
INCONSISTENCIES AND DUTIES
ACROSS THE STATE. THE C. O. E.
T. A. M. TECHNICAL SYSTEM MODEL
WILL BRING BACK NECESSARY
CONSISTENT MESSAGING AND
COOPERATION WITH CD TO SUPPORT
K. TWELVE PATHWAYS MOVING
FORWARD WITHOUT LEAVING SOME
VALLEY AS WONDERING WHERE THEY
FIT IN. AND FINALLY FOR CTE
PATHWAYS TO MAINTAIN AND GROW
IT'S A CENTRAL FOR ELLIE AS TO
HAVE ACCESS TO ON GUN GOING
STABLE FUNDING AND NOT BE
DEPENDENT ON GRANT FUNDING THAT
DOES NOT HAVE THE SUSTAINABILITY
BEYOND THE THIRTY MONTHS I'VE
EACH AWARD. WHILE THE C. T.
FUNDING FORMULA IN C. T.
ALLOCATIONS NEED REVISION FOR
EQUITY AND INCLUSION FOR ALL
STUDENTS INCLUDING COURT
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS WE ARE
OPTIMISTIC THAT THIS BILL WILL
FIX THE ISSUES TO ENSURE AN
EFFICIENT. AND IMPROVE SEATED
PROCESS BENEFITING ALL MOVING
FORWARD WITH SECURE SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING FOR C. T. I APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME AND PROBABLY SUPPORT
AB TWENTY FIFTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM
IN SUPPORT.
MATT PATTON REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO SPEAKING BEHALF
OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL BOTH
ORGANIZATIONS PART OF GET REAL
BOTH ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT.
HELLO HI LONNIE I CANNOT ON
BEHALF OF THE CTJ PA COALITION
IN TORRANCE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
SLOWLY MONTHS THAT'S SEEN WITH
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. HI MY NAME IS OLGA
SHILOH I'M WITH PROJECT LEAD THE
WAY WITH STEM EDUCATION
CURRICULUM PROVIDER AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON
JANICE RUGGIE MERCED COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATIONAL REGIONAL
OCCUPATIONAL PROGRAM. AND IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS
IT'S MCCARTY. THANK YOU- YOU
KNOW MISTER O'DONNELL I'M IN
FULL SUPPORT OF THIS WE SPOKE
ABOUT THIS YESTERDAY. IN THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE I THINK YOU'RE
HERE FOR A LITTLE BIT OF THAT-
WHAT ARE NOT WE DO IT THROUGH
THE BUDGET PROCESS WILL TRY TO
PUT A NOTE IN OUR BILL AS YOU
KNOW BUT- IT JUST IS COMMON
SENSE- THAT WE COORDINATE. OUR
EFFORTS HERE WE KNOW CT IS SUCH
THAT. YOU KNOWBIPARTISAN ISSUE
THAT WE ALL WANT MORE C. T. WE
STEPPED UP A FEW YEARS AGO AND
GAVE. ONE TIME MONEY FOR THREE
YEARS TO LAUNCH THE PROGRAM BACK
AGAIN AFTER I GOT CUT DURING THE
RECESSION NOW WE MADE THE MONEY
ON GOING BUT WE STILL COMPLICATE
THINGS LIKE YOUR WITNESS- YOU
KNOW SO GRACEFULLY OUTLINED
THERE. AND YEAH WE JUST NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU KNOW AND ARE
TENURE HERE WE FIX THIS AN
IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
ONE STRONG PROGRAM FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO FOCUS ON SO. I'LL
MOVE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ESTERLY SONORA THANK YOU SELLER
DONALD FOR THE BILL AS WE HAVE
MANY CONVERSATIONS UP TO I'M
ALSO A BIG FAN OF CITY. BUT ALSO
A BIGGER FAN OF CONSOLIDATING
AND STREAMLINING PROGRAMS I
THINK WE NEED TO MAKE SURE OUR
TAX DOLLARS ARE GOING DIRECTLY
TO STUDENTS AND EDUCATORS NOT TO
MORE MORE. BUREAUCRACY OR
ADMINISTRATION IN THAT SENSE AND
I THINK WE'RE- YOU KNOW WE'RE
VERY LUCKY TO HAVE ALMOST MORE
THAN DOUBLED OUR C. T. E. MONEY
IN THE LAST COUPLE YEARS AND I
REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
GOES IN CLASSROOMS. GET SINCE
PREPARE FUTURE EVEN A FEW. CITY
SCHOOLS IN MY REGION AND SILICON
VALLEY WHERE NOT EVERYONE WANTS
BECOME A TECH PROGRAMMER. I
THINK WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THERE
ARE MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE AND THAT'S WHAT SUPPORT
SO THAT'S WHY I'M SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY. MMHM THANK YOU SO
MUCH I'D BE HONORED TO BE A CO
AUTHOR IF YOU WOULD CONSIDER
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR-
ASIANET COMMENTS I APPRECIATE
THAT. WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND CALL THE ROLL. BUT I JUST
CLOSE REPOSITORY I JUST SAY NO
NO THANK YOU- A INTO THE- UT
COLLEGE CHANCELLORS CREDIT- HE
SHARED THAT IT WASN'T REALLY HIS
CHOICE TO HAVE THIS PROGRAM
LANA'S LAP. AND I WON'T SPEAK
FORM BUT I'LL ALSO SAY WHAT I
THOUGHT I HEARD HIM SAYING THAT
IS THAT HE WOULD BE HAPPY TO SEE
THIS PROGRAM BE MOVED OUT OF HIS
JOB AND PUT OVER HIS CD. BECAUSE
HE HAS ENOUGH WORK TO DO- SO
WITH THAT I ASKED FOR AND I HAVE
A- FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB TWO
ZERO FIVE EIGHT THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED YOUR PREPARATIONS. A
DONALD. HI DONALD HI SALLY.
SALLY I'D BENNETT. BENNETT I
CHEN. FAN I LEAD. D. I. MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE QUIRK-SILVA.
QUIRK-SILVA I. SEVEN SEVEN ZERO.
BUILD UP. WITHOUT.
I WILL NOW TURN THE HEARING AND
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADD ONS
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED. STAY
IN YOUR SEATS PLEASE IN THE-
SECRETARY WILL COME TO- ALLOW
YOU TO VOTE. I'LL START WITH
CONSENT. AND IF TWO BILLS ON
CONSENT TO IS AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY SIX FILE ITEM FOR AND
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB. TWO FOUR
SEVEN FIVE. AT THE CHAIR VOTING
I MCCARTY. RT AYE QUIRK-SILVA.
QUIRK-SILVA I'D. FILE ITEM ONE
AB SEVENTEEN OH THREE THE CHAIR
VOTING I MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
QUIRK-SILVA QUIRK-SILVA I'D.
FILE ITEM TO AB EIGHT SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN THE CHAIR VOTING I
MCCARTY. THIRTY I. QUIRK-SILVA
QUIRK-SILVA I'D. FILE ITEM THREE
THE CHAIR VOTING. FIVE-
QUIRK-SILVA BURKE SURVIVE. FILE
ITEM FIVE TEACHER VOTING I.
MCCARTY MCCARTY II QUIRK-SILVA
QUIRK-SILVA I'D. FILE ITEM SIX
A. B. TWO ZERO TWO EIGHT THE
CHURCH BUILDING I QUIRK-SILVA.
AKSEL FIVE. FILE ITEM SEVEN AB
TWO ZERO SEVEN TO THE CHAIR
VOTING I'D- QUIRK-SILVA.
QUIRK-SILVA I'D. FILE ITEM EIGHT
AB TWO ZERO EIGHT EIGHT THE
TRAVELING I MCCARTY. RT AYE
QUIRK-SILVA QUIRK-SILVA I'D.
FILE ITEM TEN AB TWO ONE TWO
FOUR THE CHAIR VOTING I'D
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE QUIRK-SILVA
. QUIRK-SILVA I. FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN AB TWO EIGHT ONE FOUR
THE CHAIR VOTING HI QUIRK-SILVA.
BURKE SURVIVE. AND FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY
THREE BUT YOU'RE VOTING I
QUIRK-SILVA. QUIRK-SILVA I.